- Hey guys, just a quick announcement,
in about five hours we are
going to be streaming live
on our Twitch.
(Joey laughs)
- Oh, you don't usually
cut to me, I was like, oh.
I mean, yes, our Twitch,
which happens to have a
link in the description
which you can go and watch.
And if you don't wanna click
a link and wanna type it
it's twitch.TV/trashtaste, podcast?
- Trash Taste Podcast.
- Okay, good. I got that right.
- We're gonna be co-streaming
the Crunchyroll Anime Awards, 2021,
so yeah, lots of anime
bands and yeah, gold times.
(all laugh)
I don't know what the fuck to say.
- So if you wanna hear our opinion.
- And all our live reactions
to the best anime of 2020.
Tune in at 5:00 P.M. PST
on twitch.tv/trashtaste,
or you can click the
link in the description.
- Also, if you're from
any other time zone,
here it is, it's on the screen.
- It's in five hours
from the episode airing,
just click the link
- Just click the link and
enjoy the episode, bye.
- TV show, what's that?
I don't watch TV shows.
- Shut the fuck up, Joey.
- I only watch, anime? Those are TV shows.
- Oh, let's not pretend you
still watch anime, Joey.
Come on, let's be real here.
- Shut up.
(gentle music)
- Welcome to this
episode of "Trash Taste",
I am the boy, the big boy.
And with me I have big boy
chungus and small boy chungus.
- Wow.
- Why am I suddenly the fattest one here?
(all laugh)
- I mean, I was gonna call... Okay, right?
I haven't seen either of
you at the gym lately,
I don't know what's
been going on with that,
but, you know, I am very disappointed.
- I mean, who was the one
that got a C in cholesterol
at the fucking like-
- Are we gonna start adding
each other that, really?
Okay, let's do it.
- I wanted to open on
that, 'cause you know what?
I was doing my usual
"Trash Taste" schedule
and shitting on the toilet,
literally before recording,
I get a phone call from Sydney,
and she said, oh, "I finally
got my health results back in,"
I'm like, "Congratulations,
what'd you get Sydney?"
And she got all A's.
- How the fuck is Sydney's liver an A?
- I'm like fuck off Sydney,
fuck off you got all A's.
- How is it that she gets all A's
and yet I got a C on my liver?
When I'm probably the
one out of the four of us
who drinks the least.
- Okay, so to give context
to this conversation.
So a few weeks ago,
if you are a regular "Trash Taste" viewer
you would know that we had our,
biannual or annual health check?
- Annual.
- Annual health check, and I didn't know-
- Which is something
that a Japanese company
forces every employee to do,
they have to go for a checkup
and the company also gets the results.
- Yes.
- And so we did our health
checkup a few weeks ago,
I talked about it on "Trash Taste",
and we just got our results back.
And this is the first time
I've ever gotten results back
from like, you know,
getting my health checkup
in a foreign company, country sorry,
and I did not know that you get graded.
- Yeah, I'm used to seeing numbers
and them saying like, "Oh, this is bad."
I'm like, oh well,
I mean, it's just a funny
number, isn't it? 220
- Yeah. Literally, I got my health checkup
and I'm just like, wait, they
are literally grading you ABC?
- It's like an end of year school report.
- Yeah, I felt like I
was doing my GCSEs again,
or A levels, I'm like, oh my God.
And normally I don't really care too much
about my health checkup 'cause-
- Unless it's bad.
- Yeah.
- Unless it bad, right?
You see numbers, you see
the doctor's suggestions,
and they're just that, they're
just doctor's suggestions.
But I don't know why,
seeing my health being
graded like a school test,
it just brought the Asian
blood out of me, right?
- Yeah, I definitely
felt more competitive.
- Yeah.
- With my body.
- 'Cause I was going
through my health checkup
and overall I got a B,
so I was like, okay,
I am a straight A student,
what the fuck did I do wrong?
- There's no B Asian, Garnt.
- No, deadass.
(laughing)
- In Asia B means bad.
- Deadass, the first thing
I did when I got my results
was I phoned up my mom and
told her how well I scored
in this exam, like a good Asian son would.
- I called up the doctor, and
I was like, just to check,
this wasn't ranked, was it?
This was casual, right?
This is free play, right?
Please say this was psyche, please.
No, but I mean my results,
I got like all As,
which was great,
I should expect from someone
who is under the age of 30,
you're generally supposed
to be quite healthy.
- Yeah.
- But I got a B on BMI,
which, I mean, obviously I'm
built a little different,
and this is Japanese BMI
which I believe is slightly different,
I don't know if I'm led
to believe that's correct.
But I mean, BMI is bullshit
anyway, a load of shit,
this is 100% muscle not fat, don't at me.
And I got a C on my cholesterol.
- Right.
- Ooh.
- But I got like a...
Well, I'm not sure how
cholesterol works exactly,
'cause I don't know shit, I'm dumb.
So they have like three
different collaterals,
and all of them were
like a little, you know,
all of them were kinds
out of touch, if you will.
- [Joey] Right
- [Garnt] Right.
- But I was like, in my head I'm like,
well they gave me three
Cs now for my cholesterol,
I'm like, but what are the odds
of one of these cholesterol being good
and the others not being
good, you know what I mean?
- Right.
- If I had amazing cholesterol,
the other two aren't gonna be like,
well, fuck, we better pick it up.
I mean, I don't know, to me it was odd.
- Mine was worse because
I got a C on my liver,
and I think a B on my heart
rate monitoring or something?
- Right.
- Oh, really?
- And everything else was an A.
- Right.
- What does that mean?
- That's the thing. It's
like, usually on your thing,
I think you too got like
a doctor's note, right?
- Mh-hm.
- Did you guys get a doctor's summary?
- So you can ask when you get the thing,
I don't know if you said yes or no.
You can ask if you want advice,
and I said, no, I don't want advice.
- I said no either,
but I still got like...
I don't know if it's
the same doctor's note
that we're talking about, but
it was just like a summation
of the test results.
- Which didn't explain anything.
- No, it didn't explain.
It just said some of the values are a bit,
you know, abnormal, which is, you know,
higher or lower than we expect,
but there shouldn't be
anything to worry about.
- I didn't even get a summation.
- Did you not?
- Mine literally, like overall,
I got a C and the summation
box was just blank.
- Oh yeah, mine too.
- So what, you're just gonna tell me
that my liver is bad and that's it?
- Should I be worried?
- I feel like context would help, right?
- Yeah.
- Did you get a note that
said you had to come in
three months later as
well? Like Connor did.
- I did, I got that.
They told me to go back in
three months, but it's optional.
- I mean, on the thing it
says, like if you get a C,
they recommend you come
back three months later,
although I didn't get a note
saying that I should come back.
- Mine said you should
come back in three months,
but you have to pay for it.
And also, you know, for cholesterol,
I'm obviously gonna turn up
and they're gonna be like,
"Hey, you should exercise
and eat healthy."
I'm like, "Thanks Doc."
- I was gonna ask, 'cause I heard
you're back on the chicken
and broccoli diets.
- No, I haven't gone right back
to the chicken and broccoli.
- Okay.
- I have started eating a little more
health conscious though.
- Is it because of the test results?
- I think it helped, helped
me be a bit more conscious.
It made me, you know, when
you would maybe just go
for the karaage, or
you'd go for the chips?
It made me like second think,
like, do I really want it?
- I mean, I definitely
have like stopped drinking.
(all laugh)
I think I've only drank
like once or twice since.
- Is the liver, 100% all
problems come from alcohol?
'Cause I feel like it's not just that,
there's gotta be a whole
host of other things.
- Yeah, it's probably not.
- 'Cause the problem with
the test results is that
they gave you the grade
but they didn't tell you
how to improve it.
And I guess that was our bad
'cause we literally ticked the box
that said we don't want doctor's advice.
Because I had assumed, like
any other health checkup,
that it would just be like, you know, the-
- That you're gonna be good, right?
- Yeah, it was just like the generic,
you know, are you doing well?
Do I need to go to the hospital
to really have a lifestyle change? No.
But as soon as I saw the fucking B,
'cause I got a B in my blood,
and I'm just like how the
fuck do I improve my blood?
What am I doing wrong?
Why is my blood a B?
- Just improve your NaN?
Just like control it.
- 'Cause they were like going on like,
you know, the white blood or T-cell,
I'm not a fucking uh, I'm
not a medical student.
- I saw the numbers,
I just saw the A, I was
like I'm (indistinct).
- Yeah, I saw the B and I'm
just like, as an Asian student,
you know, 'cause whenever
I saw a B in a test,
I'm like, okay, I can
improve this test score.
I can study a bit more,
I can optimize this a bit more somehow.
- What I found interesting was that like,
I always thought to myself that
I was very deaf for my age,
because I went to a lot
of concerts growing up,
and just basically destroyed my ears
through headphones and shit like that.
So I was expecting, on the hearing part,
that I maybe get like a
B or something, right?
I wouldn't even have complained about it.
But then I saw I got an A,
so I was like, oh, it's not that I'm deaf,
it's just that I don't listen.
(all laugh)
It kinda made me realize,
I was like, oh okay,
I'm glad to know.
I don't have a hearing problem,
I just have like an attention problem.
- I just don't give a shit.
- That's my problem.
- I was telling my
company, I was like listen,
if my eyesight or my ears come back shit,
I know exactly why that is.
And that's because I didn't know
what the fuck was happening
when they were talking to me.
- Oh really?
- They just put the headphones on me,
I'm like, wait what? Wait, whoa.
Then she asked me, luckily
I just caught her asking,
can you hear, in Japanese,
like, can you hear it?
And I'm like, hear what?
What am I listening for?
And then I realized,
'cause I had done the "Human
Benchmark" test recently,
that it was the frequency thing.
So you say when you can hear it.
But I was like, what am I
hearing for, like a burp?
I didn't know what was happening.
So I was like, oh okay, shit, all right.
- Yeah, how did she...
Because with the eyesight thing, right?
You have to do like
the, it's like a circle
but it's cut out, right?
- Yeah.
- How did you guys say that in English?
- No, I said it in Japanese.
- Or did you just point?
(speaking in Japanese)
- Oh right.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I really fucked
up in the eyesight thing,
because I didn't know what
they were looking for.
So I thought it was a
normal eyesight test thing,
where now it's just like, E, A, because...
Okay, so to explain the eyesight thing,
they have this circle
and have one of like,
either up, down, left
or right that's cut out.
- No, the diagonals as well, are cut out.
- I didn't see diagonals.
- There was no diagonals.
- Yeah, there were diagonals.
- No there wasn't.
- No, I only saw up, down, left, right.
- No, there were diagonals.
- No, 'cause I got all of them right.
- Yeah I did too, but
there were diagonals,
- There was no diagonals.
There was no diagonals.
- The one they gave me, they
usually have diagonals, right?
- I've never seen diagonals.
Because the only reason
I knew about this test
is 'cause when I exchanged
my driving license
from British to Japanese, I
had to do the exact same thing.
And it was this exact same thing again,
and there was no diagonals.
- I mean, I definitely got it right,
'cause I came back with like a 1.2.
- 'Cause you got me like,
what the fuck is this man
talking about diagonals?
What the fuck?
- Yeah, because right
next to the circle thing,
you had like the letters as well.
So I was just reading out letters
when they were asking what direction,
sir, what direction is
missing from this circle?
- O, O, O, O.
- 'Cause I was wondering why
she was looking at me really weird.
And she kept asking me,
"Can you see, can you see?
And I'm just like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah,
let me just read out the letters for you."
- So why are they all
Os? This is easy as fuck.
- Yeah, luckily I'd done
the simulation before,
so that's why I was not
panicking as much, but yeah, man.
I mean, I clicked no to the health advice
'cause I just figured
that it was gonna be
the same old, you know.
- Eat healthy.
- Yeah, 'cause let's be honest, right?
Unless it's something
bad, like really bad,
that actually requires treatment, right?
They're just gonna tell me,
"Hey, you should exercise
more and eat healthy,"
and I do most of that anyway.
- Because, I think for
cholesterol it's pretty simple.
- Unless you just like to eat.
- But for some of them, like
for example, liver or blood,
you look at that result.
- Your blood's a little yikes.
- Yeah.
- It's like a number of factors, right?
It's like, what do you even start with?
- How do I improve my white
blood cell count? I don't know.
Do I just take an injection
of white blood cells?
What do you want me to do?
- I have a theory, right?
This could be a very pleasant
theory, I don't know.
My theory was, 'cause we
got this health checkup done
right after like Christmas,
and my theory was,
well I've just been
drinking and eating straight
for like three weeks.
This is just, clearly
we've gotta write this off,
this doesn't count man.
Of course my collateral
is gonna be higher,
I had like 8,000 calories three days ago,
of course it's gonna be higher.
- Sure.
(chuckling)
- Maybe, I don't know.
- I did drink a lot in
Christmas so that might be it.
- Yeah.
- I ate so much.
- Yeah, my cholesterol is terrible.
- I think I definitely skewed the results,
that's what I'm gonna chalk it down to.
- They're wrong, science is wrong.
- Doctors out there, please
validate me in the comments.
I don't wanna hear it if you
have an alternative theory,
just say if I'm right.
- Yeah, I just found it funny how, like,
I think this is definitely the difference
between Asian and Western culture,
where I feel like in Asia, living in Asia,
they try to make everything a test,
and everything kind of competitive.
And that's how I was raised as well
so whenever I see a grade
something in my blood drives me
to try and improve that grade.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Yeah, and I don't know if
I'm just like over-competitive,
or I just, maybe-
- Well I think it's good, right?
Because if you're the kind
of person who you are,
those things work really well.
But there's obviously some
personalities out there
that when they hear, oh, by
the way, your BMI is bad,
or your liver's bad,
where they're just like,
instead of wanting to be like,
well fuck you, I'm gonna improve it,
it's like, oh shit, I guess
it's just like, there's no hope.
Like why is it not working?
And then they just make it worse, right?
- Yeah, but I don't know,
I feel like as someone
who grew up in, you know,
kind of both cultures, I
think a lot of toxicity
can come in putting so much
value into a grade or a test.
And I feel like definitely living in Asia,
they put way too much
value into test results
and score results.
- Do you think there are
some schools and companies
where they get bullied if
you got like a bad rating
on one of your health tests?
- I think, totally, it's
definitely a thing in Asia.
- Look at this mo-fo who
got a D in his blood.
- Yeah, because in Asia, I
dunno if I'm talking out my ass,
but you see in like anime definitely,
where you get the test results, right?
And it's like publicly posted.
- Yeah.
- So you publicly know what
your fellow classmates got.
- Yeah.
- And that to me seems
like a lot of pressure.
- They do that for university,
like entrance exams as well.
- That's fucking rude.
- Yeah.
- They create a huge billboard
in front of the school
and it has like your number on it,
and if your number doesn't
show up, you basically failed.
It's like a public execution
- Yeah, they literally make
a public tournament arc
for your test results.
- It's brutal.
- No wonder they put so
much value on tests here.
And I think that can definitely,
to me, from my experience,
can definitely skew with your mentality
when you go out of schooling
and you realize that not
everything in life is graded,
and not everything in life
has a percentage or a grade
that judges your results
and how well you do.
- Yeah, I think especially,
given the industry that we've gone into,
which is entertainment, if you will,
I don't know if you'd call
"Trash Taste" entertainment
but we're trying our best here.
I feel like the skill set is nearly 180
in compares of what you
learn in school, right?
It's purely based on like,
I feel like social skills
are 90% of our job, right?
Being able to read a room,
being able to talk, you know?
I mean, obviously there is
a lot of technical aspects,
obviously, like learning how
to set up all this equipment,
but the majority of it can't
be taught in a classroom.
- [Joey] Oh no.
- And you can't really grade it, you know?
How can you grade someone's social skills?
Imagine we start doing that?
- Ooh, I mean...
(all laughing)
- Could you imagine it?
Oh, Connor, you were an ass,
but ever since the event happened
you've been kind of a bummer,
you're kind of a D now,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's like getting graded
for every tweet you make, right?
- Honestly, if Japan-
- It's like, oh, that was
a B plus tweet right there.
- Yeah, true. Asia is gonna find a way.
- Yeah, true.
- I mean, I went through a period in life
where, you know, I was
the stereotypical wiebe
that didn't go out, and I
have zero social skills.
And how I learned was,
I think everyone goes through that stage
especially if you go through university
where you kind of wanna
reinvent yourself, right?
You move in to somewhere new
and you wanna be a new person.
So what I did was I basically
just had like a full year
where I just went out as much as possible
and talked to as many people as possible,
just like try to go
out of my comfort zone.
And that was hell for me
as like this introvert,
it was kind of like a trial
by fire period of my life
that I would never wanna do again.
- Garnt's "300" spartan
training with social structures.
- It basically was,
'cause I literally just did
not know how to socialize.
I didn't know how to read a room,
I didn't know what the social norms were.
- That's such a common
cultural thing in Japan,
that we actually have our
own like phrase for it,
which is university debut.
- Really?
- Yeah, it's like a
cultural thing in Japan
where because there are
so many anti-social kids
in middle school and high school,
and that when they go into university,
they're like, oh shit,
I'm like one step closer
to where I have to socialize
in order to fucking live in society.
So university is literally my last chance
before I'm thrown into that world.
So I'm gonna like make
a 180 during university
and just fucking do anything
and everything possible
to just completely change myself around.
- I think it is a really
Opie mindset, you know,
'cause I wasn't cool at all in school,
I was like very much an
in-betweener, you know?
I wasn't cool, but I wasn't on the bottom
of the social ladder, if you will.
- You weren't like bullied to shit, right?
- I mean that's 'cause
I started fighting back.
(all laugh)
I clawed my way out of the bottom.
- Yeah.
- You know, I was just
kinda like whatever,
no one really paid attention to me,
never had any luck with
dating or anything,
I never had anything of that.
But then I thought like, Oh wait,
like no one knows who I am in university,
so no one knows I'm a mid tier social,
(laughing)
I'm a C-tier on the social ladder, right?
Like I can reinvent myself.
And I didn't, you know,
I didn't reinvent myself,
it's just like you don't do the mistakes,
you don't fall back on
crutches that you had,
like you said, right? You go out more.
You know, I could play video games,
which was what I probably
would prefer doing,
but if people invite me out, I'll say yes
'cause you wanna be seen as fun,
and if you seem as fun
everything goes easier,
and you learn more, and you
get more confident, and it's...
Go out of your comfort zone.
- For me it was like
the complete opposite.
I was really social in middle
school and high school,
and then when I entered university,
because I started doing YouTube,
I kind of regressed socially.
- But you also lived at home, right?
- Yeah, I lived at home.
- I can imagine that's like way...
You must feel, did you feel different
from the other people who were
living on campus and stuff?
- Yeah, a little bit.
I mean, our campus was weird
because I think the majority
of people in my class
did live at home.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah, we only had maybe
like a handful of people
who actually lived on campus.
- Which university did you go to again?
- Sydney University.
- Okay, so I guess, 'cause
it's a city university.
- Yeah, I mean, we have our own campus
and dormitories and stuff like that,
that uni students live in.
But I think the majority of people,
because it's such an
accessible university,
'cause it's like smack bang
in the middle of Sydney City,
so people can just get on trains and buses
and just go home basically.
- Yeah, cause I feel like-
- There was no one in my class
who lived locally to the
area, like who was from there.
- Well, that's because you
went to Swanzey, right?
- Yeah.
- What is there to do in Swanzey?
- Well, that's a good question, Garnt.
I'm still wondering that myself.
(all laughing)
I'm yet to find the answer.
- I mean, to be fair. I
didn't live locally either,
I lived like an hour and a half by bus.
- Fuck.
- So I didn't live close at all.
I could have, like, I was at a distance
where I could have
easily lived on the dorm.
But then I heard from people
who were living in dorms
in Sydney University, they
were like, don't do it.
- But you could experience them, you know?
Being thrown into hell.
- Honestly, I feel like I learned more
valuable social skills,
and just life skills,
going to university than
I did actual career skills
that I learned from my course.
- I don't think I
realized it until I left,
and then I actually
started like functioning
on my own, you know?
- I don't know what I would have done
without that period in my life, Jesus.
It basically taught me how
to survive in the world
and how people really are,
and all the expectations I had growing up.
'Cause as a kid, right?
You kind of expect that as you grow up
and the more mature you get,
you assume that everyone's
just gonna realize what
they're doing, get mature.
And then you kind of realize,
going through university especially,
that that was a fucking lie.
And then you go out of the university,
start like the working
world and you realize,
oh, everyone here is just like
grown up university students
and nobody actually
knows what they're doing,
and everyone is still secretly as immature
as they were before.
- It's like adults aren't as adult
as I thought they were, right?
- Yeah. I don't know.
I feel like I don't...
It's either like people just
have their shit together
or they don't, like there's no in-between,
like, I don't know.
I've never met anyone-
- Most adults that I've met
are just like kids in suits essentially.
- That's basically the
best way I can describe it.
And especially seeing
some of the recent stuff
that's been happening,
obviously stuff like, let's say like...
Can we talk about how-
- The stonk market?
- Can we talk about the stonk market
that we've recently just seen?
- Yeah, we're gonna be
very delayed from you guys-
- We are gonna be very
delayed because it's a very-
- To us it's just happened.
- To us it's just
happened or is happening,
I don't fucking know, it's a
constantly evolving situation.
So by the time this airs,
everything we're probably gonna be saying
is gonna be outdated.
- Who knows? The stock
market might not even exist
by the time this comes out.
- My God, when reality
is this entertaining,
who the fuck needs TV?
- This is what I'm saying,
this is what I've always said,
real life is so much more interesting.
You couldn't make a movie about like,
if you would have pitched
a movie being like,
so what happens is a
bunch of Redditors, right?
They buy game stock,
and they fuck over these
billion dollar head...
Everyone will think that's fucking stupid,
but if it happens,
it's like this is the
coolest fucking story.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Thus, documentaries
are better than movies.
- Yeah, and I just think we
are reaching a time period
where, you know, it
used to be a funny meme,
but now memes are just...
Real life memes, big memes now,
are basically just making fun
of real life events, you know?
- Yeah, pretty much.
- And having a real life
effect on the world,
that is what memes are
growing into it now.
- I think I saw someone on Twitter saying,
they were like, this is
kind of the revitalization
of it's just a prank bro,
but the pranks have actually
gone far, gone wrong.
(chuckles)
I'm not gonna lie, the
first time I saw that story
I was like I don't know
what the fuck is happening,
and I'm really scared to ask.
- Dude, when it was happening,
I was like what the fuck
does shorting a stock mean?
- Yeah.
- And now I'm just like,
now because of this meme
I've done so much research
that I'm just like,
maybe I should get into
the stock market, you know?
It's really weird because-
- Have you yoloed.
- I have not yoloed, no.
- Are you gonna yolo that
YouTube money away, Garnt?
- Look, I'm not a gambling addict, okay?
A much as much as the "Gotcha"
episode might've been real,
look, I am not a gambling addict.
- He'll yolo on "Gotcha"
but not on stocks.
- But it's made me think a lot
about my grown up investments,
the grown investments talk
that I just never really
thought about before.
- It's weird because
I've been doing stocks,
like through like my dad,
'cause my dad is really in business.
So I've been doing it but
when this shit happened
I was like, should I be
scared? Like what's happening?
I didn't know what was happening.
- Dad, is our money safe? Daddy, daddy?
- Daddy, please, is my money okay? Please.
- I mean, no one in my family
has had anything about it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think every single
generation of my family
has just like made enough to get by,
and do buy some nice
things here and there,
so I don't think stocks
was ever on their mind.
I think my parents had some stocks
in the companies they
worked for, as like a gift,
so I think my dad checks
up on those stocks.
But in terms of actually
knowing about the stock market,
you know, no one in my
family has any idea.
- Right, because it's not something
that everyone commonly learns, right?
- But that's... What I was thinking-
- It's only fancy gambling
for rich men really.
- Yeah.
- That's what it's like
marketed as, right?
But I mean, I was doing my research
and properly reading into
this, you know, I was thinking,
why the fuck aren't we
taught this in school?
Because I feel like,
especially knowledge on the stock market,
a lot of the reasons why
people don't get into the stock market,
from what I realized, is because
nobody knows shit about it.
It's because nobody was
taught this in school
and it sounds so complicated
that nobody has the effort
or energy to really read
up and learn about this.
I mean, I didn't, and the only reason
I started reading up about this
was because the fucking
stock market was on fire
and it turned into a massive meme.
I literally started reading up
about this because of a meme.
- Who would have thought that memes
get you to go into like
educational adventures?
- It happens all the time, man.
- But hey, look, what
this made me think was,
why weren't we taught
about this in school?
Growing up, there's so many
life essential knowledge
that I think everyone should know.
- To be fair though, I'm thinking back,
like when you were like 15, 14, right?
- You wouldn't have paid attention.
- You know, they always say
like, oh, why didn't they teach
kids about taxes in school as well?
Because no one-
- I do think there are however-
- Because no one would fucking care.
- I think even if you
aren't, even with taxes,
I do think that there
should have been something.
- Yeah I agree, there
- There should be something
so at least when you get
to that point in life
you are aware and you
can go back to be like,
oh, this is why it was important.
- Yeah.
- Because there's so many things,
Like, for example, I don't
know why it's not compulsory
to have a financial
management course in school.
There should be, there totally should be,
because financial management
is such an adult life essential skill,
and it's something that you have to learn
by just either, one, your
parents teaching it to you,
or two, fucking up and realizing
that this is an important
skill you need to know.
- Instead schools are
like, no, let's learn
the quadratic equation,
you will need that.
- But no, let's learn that there are-
- That's pretty useful actually.
You're drawing on the quadratic equation,
it's a very good equation.
- Let's learn that there are
180 degrees in a triangle,
I've used that before in my life.
Let's learn about the tangents,
and the cosine and the sine.
- (indistinct) is the
powerhouse of the sound,
I don't know if you know that.
Well, you know, I think why
they should be teaching,
like taxes and financial advice in school,
is not so that you get,
'cause obviously kids
aren't gonna fucking come out of school
being like, hello, let me do your taxes.
It's just so that when they leave school,
it's on the back of their mind.
That like, I've been
taught that this is a thing
that's gonna come up
and that I should learn
how it works for my value.
- Yeah, exactly. The whole point of school
I feel should be at least preparing you
for what you're gonna
face in the adult world,
and, you know, there can be
some specialized courses.
You know, I memed it
but I can understand why
they teach mathematics and algebra,
in case you want to pursue that.
But what I am saying is there are so many
life essential knowledge that
I had to learn on the fly,
and everyone does,
and I was just not taught
this stuff in school.
And I'm thinking, why the fuck
is this not taught in school?
- And the thing is, is that like, yeah,
you know, people can argue
being like, you know,
Oh, who needs to know the
fucking quadratic equation,
what people are doing...
It's like architecture
or like math based stuff,
but like financial advice
and taxes and shit like that,
it doesn't matter what job you go into
you're gonna have to
deal with it as an adult.
- Yeah, I mean, there's so
many things in my school
that we were taught that
were replaceable in my mind.
Like we would do like media studies,
where we would just analyze
newspapers and shit,
and just talked about the media,
and how they advertise their stuff.
It's in my job now
but I didn't even get
anything useful from that.
- Yeah, I had to do that as well.
- Yeah, it's fucking stupid.
- Oh, I didn't have to do that.
- And then I did like
cooking which was stupid
'cause, let's be honest,
I'm not a good cook.
As I'm sure guys will find out.
- Let's be honest, Uber
Eats is a thing now.
(all laugh)
- I'ma be honest, make
money, get Uber Eats,
that's what it's all about.
- Yeah,
- No, but, you know, they
could've replaced it,
and I think that, um...
Fuck, what was I gonna say?
Fuck, I totally forgot my
point now, fuck. I'm done.
Go back to you, I'll figure
out what I wanted to say.
- Okay, I'm just saying
like there's so many
important things in life
that I just don't know about, you know?
Like for example, I have no idea
about anything about mortgages
or anything like that,
and when I say mortgage... You
say the word mortgage, right?
And you're like, oh
okay, you are a grownup.
You know, as a kid you
hear the word mortgage,
and you're just like, I don't
need to worry about that,
that's grown up shit.
- Yeah, I had to learn
that shit on the fly.
I was like, I don't know
what the fuck this is about.
- But the thing is, everyone
should aim to own a house,
or own some property,
that's like one of the
final goals in life, right?
And yet nobody's taught
this shit in school.
- I'm like, is it bad the only time
I've ever heard the word
mortgage was in a monopoly game?
That's the only time I've heard of it.
- And you know what? I still have no-
- I still don't know how to
mortgage in a monopoly game.
- Exactly, I still have like
the bare bones basic idea
about mortgage because I've
not gone through the process
of buying a house, because
that shit sounds scary to me.
- Yeah, it is.
- I did go and see a mortgage advisor
just 'cause I wanted
to learn more about it,
and my bank had it for like,
they were like free consultations.
I had no intention of getting a mortgage,
I just wanted to know how they worked.
- Yeah, because I feel like
you should know how they work.
- Yeah, so I went and then,
just this really awkward thing
of like, so what do you do?
And I'm like, oh well, so I make videos,
about like anime, this is the time.
And then he was like, "Okay,
like, this is your income?"
And I was like, yeah,
and he's like, "It changed
a lot in one year."
I'm like, yeah, yeah it does that,
it could go up or down, I don't know.
And I'm there thinking
I should just tell him
as little about my job as possible
otherwise he's gonna be like,
"This guy is a financial risk,
I can't give him a mortgage."
But yeah, I mean it was
pretty standard stuff.
I mean, there's different rates and stuff,
but you don't need to
fucking worry about it.
- Yeah, I mean, I had to sit down
with our family financial advisor,
like I had to go through-
- That's the most privileged thing
you've ever said in your life.
(all laughing)
Holy shit!
- I never had a financial advisor.
- No, it's because my parents
are super into the housing
market and the stock market
and shit like that, so it was just like,
you're an adult now-
- That still sounds privileged.
- Yeah.
- You can talk to this man in a suit
that comes to our house every so often,
and you'd think he's our lawyer.
I used to call him our lawyer
'cause I didn't know who
the fuck this guy was,
I was like, there's a man in
a suit, he must be a lawyer.
- Bro, check your wealth, Joe
(all laugh)
- This episode is sponsored by Harry's,
Quality Grooming and Shaving Supplies.
- Gentlemen, we all have beards,
except for Garnt who shaved.
- No, I do shave, and
that's why I use Harry's.
- Man, I just hate it
when I have to choose
between price and quality,
but thanks to Harry's,
that's no longer a problem
I have to suffer with.
- You mean you can get
both at the same time?
- Yes Garnt, you can.
- That's illegal.
(Garnt laughs)
Harry's delivers a close
comfortable shave at a fair price,
only $2 per refill.
- Goddamn.
- Harry's believes in quality so much
that they bought their
own factory in Germany.
Connor's favorite country,
so you know that it works.
Connor, just how do they do it?
- Garnt, I'm glad you asked.
Harry's team combined a
simple ergonomic design
with five sharp blades, they
sourced their steel from Sweden
and manufactured their blades
in their world-class blade factory.
Isn't that a fate arc?
- Are you telling me that
Harry's has min-maxed shaving,
and shaving products? Guys.
- Thank God.
- Harry's German factory is one of the few
select manufacturers in the world
that have mastered the technology
to create a Gothic arch,
the gold standard of blade razor grinding
- This sounds epic, like an anime arc.
But thank God, they also stand behind
the quality of their blades so much
that they offer 100% money
back guarantee on harry's.com
- 100%?
- Right.
- For a limited time, Harry's
has an exclusive offer
for listeners of "Trash Taste".
New customers can get
a Harry's starter set
and a free body wash for just $3
by going to harrys.com/trash taste.
That's over a $16 value
for just a measly $3.
- What do they get out of that?
- I'll tell you what they get;
You'll get a five blade
razor, weighted handle,
foaming shaving gel, a travel cover,
and a travel-size body wash
- That's an incredible deal.
- As Joey just said, that
is an incredible deal
but you have to act fast
while supplies last.
So go to harrys.com/trashtaste
to redeem your offer today.
Thank you to Harry's for
sponsoring this episode,
back to the video.
- So then when I became an adult
and I started making a little
bit of money on YouTube,
they were like, okay, you
can talk to our 'lawyer' now,
who turned out to be a financial advisor.
So I was like okay, I don't
know what to do with this money,
please help me.
'Cause otherwise it's just
gonna collect in a bank,
probably do fucking nothing.
And he's like, well, you
could, you know, mortgage,
and I'm like, that word.
Oh no, that word.
- Ideally anyone with any kind of savings
would have a financial advisor,
sadly, you know, it's kind of
difficult to get a good one
or get one that even...
- Like understands, right?
- Yeah.
- I mean yeah, I had to fucking like sit-
- I would if I could, I mean,
I don't fucking know anyone.
- I had sit the guy down to be like,
okay, this is what I do.
And he was like, "Wait, so you make videos
and you get paid to do that?"
And I'm like, yeah, and he's like, okay.
- I mean, I would love a financial advisor
because there's so little I know about it,
and this kind of, the
wall street bet thing
that's been going on has
really just opened my eyes
to how little I know about this stuff
that I feel like I really should know.
- Yeah.
- Like a YouTuber I've
been watching recently
is a guy called, I think
it's Graham Spector, I think?
- The millionaire guy?
- Yeah, the millionaire guy.
I saw him in other videos
where he was talking about,
he seems like the most
grounded millionaire I've ever-
- I couldn't stand him at
first, he seemed like a dick,
and then I started
watching and I was like,
all right, okay, he's pretty cool.
But he just came off as like an ass.
- The biggest thing that me
off is every episode he goes,
he does the, "But don't
forget to like and subscribe,
if you like the video",
and like, no matter how
cool a person you are,
if you say it,
- Immediate turn off.
- Ironically, yeah, immediate turn off.
But I was watching some of the videos
and some of the advice
that he gave, which was,
some of it was just like
really basic financial advice
about how to manage your money.
And the thing is, he gives
advice that any person
from any level of income
can take to heart.
'Cause like one of the ideas
that he really tried to propagate is like,
no matter how much earn,
everyone should get this in their mindset,
that you can invest something.
- Yeah, that's what I understood as well.
- Because I had grown up with the mindset
of like the word, investment,
that's for rich people,
that's for privileged people.
I, I can't invest, I don't
have the money to invest.
But even just investing
a fraction of your paycheck or something,
in the long-term can
really help you financially
and give you a lot of financial stability.
And this is the stuff that
we were just never taught.
- I guess as well, 'cause you
hear so many horror stories
about investments going wrong,
and you also hear about like,
you know, people who
take advantage of people,
you know, a fake financial
advisor who says,
"Oh, I'll help you out with your money,"
and then just runs off with it, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's so scary to trust someone
with any amount of money,
and, you know, even if
you have barely anything,
it's still all you have, right?
And it's scary to give that to someone,
and be like, oh, I trust you
to take care of this, right?
- 'Cause the way that I was taught up,
because, you know, I also didn't come from
like the most well-off family.
- You didn't have a lawyer
or a financial advisor?
- I did not.
- You didn't have a
family financial advisor?
I thought everyone had one of those.
- My parents declared bankruptcy
when I was a teenager.
- Oh shit.
- Yeah, so I grew up with
a mentality that, you know,
you should try to keep your money as safe,
you should gather up as much as possible.
And I realized how much
this mentality had affected
how I think about just
resources in general.
So what I realized is that
I am that gamer, right?
I am that gamer who, you know,
whenever you play an RPG-
- You don't use any of the precious-
- And you get a rare item-
- You don't use it.
- Yeah, I don't use it.
(Joey laughs)
- And whenever I play,
like "Command And Conquer"
or something, or some RTS games, right?
I wait until I have a
fuck ton of resources,
and then I start buying stuff out.
And I realized, I realized this this week,
when I when I was like,
where did this come from?
And I realized, oh, it's
because that's just how
I manage my money,
and I've always come in the
mindset of I've gotta save this
just in case of a rainy day.
I can't invest it, I need to save it
because, you know, investing
money might be risky
so it's better to just save it.
And, you know, I kind of realized this
as I was doing research and
I learned a lot about myself
this past week because of a fucking meme.
- 'Cause a lot of entrepreneurs
are spending everything they have,
just goes right into buying
shit, they have no savings,
it's just all in the businesses.
- Well it's all just high
risk, high reward, right?
- Yeah, but then also as well, you know,
online there's so much of those fake,
stupid entrepreneurs online
that have just really ruined,
in my mind, the image of an entrepreneur,
like a speed run ruin in like five years.
- If I go on like a
Twitter, or a social media,
and it has the word entrepreneur on it,
- Oh my god.
(all laugh)
Here's the thing, right?
10 years ago, entrepreneur,
was probably one of the
coolest things you could say.
- It's like damn, you're an entrepreneur?
- Now I just think, oh you're just doing
a fucking multi-level
marketing scam to me,
or you're selling me a course
on how to be more confident.
Have you seen those courses?
- Yeah.
- Those things are insane, they cost like,
it's like $1,000 for the first course.
- And then they're like, all
right now you've unlocked
the ability to get the
next level of the course,
for only $5,000, and it blows my mind.
- They're like trying to teach you shit
that can't be learned.
- Right.
- Yeah, but it blows my mind
that people buy into this stuff.
'Cause they're obviously just people
who are spending the
money you're giving them
on this lavish lifestyle, that
then they sell back to you.
Like it's insane, and I don't know how
people get sucked into this.
Like when we were talking
about the gambling stuff,
I can understand how somebody
can get into gambling.
and you can gamble away.
I don't understand how someone
can watch these entrepreneurs, right?
These fake entrepreneurs talk about
how they can make you loads of money
and they can tell you how to be like,
there's loads like realtors,
have you seen those?
- Yeah.
- Like, I could teach you
the best real estate course of your life,
just come here for $100 and
then have someone else teach it,
and then add five more classes,
I'm like, how does
someone believe this shit?
It's all fake obviously, I don't get it.
- I mean, someone believes
this shit because there's...
I think the biggest problem is that
there's so much information
out there right now
that you don't know who to believe.
I mean I can see when someone
knows nothing about...
- Yeah, I know nothing about many things.
- Yeah.
- But I also know when someone's
shouting out of their ass,
you know what I mean?
- You have a bullshit detector.
(all laugh)
- Yeah.
- A lot of people don't
have a bullshit detector.
- A $500 paywall right
off the gate for a lesson
is normally the first indication of that.
- Well, I think to a
lot of people, you know,
they see that paywall and
they see the presentation
and they think, oh, well
this is probably legit.
- Yeah, I mean I'm putting money into this
so that must mean the advice is legit.
- If I have to pay this
much for this course
then it must bring results.
- Yeah, maybe I just can't see that
'cause obviously we're doing entertainment
and you see how fake things are, right?
- We've been on the internet
for long enough to know
what's bullshit or not, right?
- Also, we're producing content,
I know what fake content
looks like, right?
I can imagine how it was made
and what tactic was used to push that.
- Yeah, because whenever
I see one of those
marketing trailers of like,
oh, you can learn X amount
and earn X amount.
I swear they all have the
same fucking templates.
- They do.
- With the same inspiring
stock-like music.
- "The first year I made $3,000,
the next month after
that I made $1 million."
And it's like, oh, I'm sure
you did, I'm sure you did.
Off mugging everyone off.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's like the equivalent
of going on a piracy site,
and then seeing the adverts of,
I earned $10,000 from filling out surveys.
And you're like, who the
fuck actually clicks on this
and believes this stuff?
(all laughing)
- It is the con on porn ads, right?
- The fact that you're
advertising on like,
not even PornHub, but like
it's some shady hentai website.
- Eat this pill and your dick will grow
three times the size in three months.
- I mean, now that I'm
thinking about it more,
it must come from targeting
insecurities, right?
- Absolutely, yeah.
- Like it must come from like,
some people are already insecure
about their financial amount, right?
And I'm sure there's
other things like that.
I mean I just realized now, why
would they offer dick pills?
Oh, because people are pretty insecure
about their dick not working, right?
So it's probably the same kind of-
- Yeah, and they don't
know any better, right?
They just think like, well
I want just the quickest,
easiest, like most straightforward way
to get a lot of money,
oh, look at this ad.
- It's a harsh lesson in life to learn
that miracles truly don't exist.
- Yeah.
- Who would have thought that you need
to actually put the work and effort into-
- If your dick doesn't
work, that might just be,
that might be a lifelong thing.
- Yeah, exactly.
I don't think any amount of
pills is gonna save you, dude.
- There's only so many times
you can pop that Viagra,
you what I mean?
- Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, I feel like it's the same reason
why people fall for
multilevel marketing scams.
- Apparently that's really bad in the U.S.
I have a lot of friends from the U.S
who tell me that they have
loads of their friends
from high school who tell them that,
they're constantly messaging about it.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I don't know how bad it is.
It could just be that I'm
connected to strange people
who have strange friends.
Meilyne, do you have friends
who have multilevel marketing people?
You do?
- [Meilyne] They tried to
sell me alkaline water.
- Alkaline water.
(all laugh)
- Tried to sell you alkaline water.
- Ladies and gentlemen, I have
won case, my proof is there.
- I mean yeah, I know a few
people from America as well.
- You do?
- Yeah, maybe not like-
- Directly, but you know people who know-
- Yeah, I know people, and
even, I think Sydney's mom,
has on occasion messaged Sydney
about this nice little scheme
that can make her money,
but you know, Sydney obviously steps in.
And it's because, I mean,
it really preys on people
who are looking for that out,
looking for that out in their life.
you know, when you're
stuck at a dead-end job,
and you are old enough where you feel
like you're kind of stuck here,
you're not young enough
to do something crazy
or just quit everything and
you have responsibilities.
You know, you kind of look for a way
that can get you out of this
lifestyle, whatever that is.
And sometimes, I mean, that's why-
- I mean, don't get me wrong.
Oh, I was gonna say
like, don't get me wrong,
like, you know, in order to
get out of that kind of stuff,
risk taking is definitely a
thing that you have to do.
- There's risk taking and
there's making mistakes.
- Right, there's responsible risk taking
where you'll always have a
fallback if it doesn't work out,
and then there's just a risk take
where you just yolo it.
- Yeah, at the end of the day, right?
Let's be honest, right?
The way life works,
if somebody had a million
dollar idea, right?
A stranger isn't gonna come
up to you and pitch it to you,
they're gonna fucking do it themselves.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Right? Like if anyone comes up to you
promising to make you money,
that should be the biggest
red flag in existence.
- Nobody can promise to make you money.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- For example-
- And if that person also
promising to make you that money
isn't a billionaire themselves,
why the aren't they doing it?
- Yeah, exactly. When I realized where...
What I've realized
growing up is, you know,
my mum and dad would give me advice
about how to be successful in X and Y,
and I love my mum and dad,
but then I came to a
point when I realized that
some of the mentality,
especially when managing money,
was not wrong per se,
because that's the mentality
that they had to survive,
because that's the
environment that they were in.
- It was just different, yeah.
- Yeah, it was a different environment,
and I gotta realize I'm growing up
under different circumstances,
and I have to, you know,
I have to choose sometimes
whenever some advice does pertain
to me and when it doesn't.
And when someone's
promising you to make money,
that's like, okay, we're three
successful YouTubers, right?
But as much advice as we
can give we cannot promise
a random person to make
them a successful YouTuber.
- Right.
- [Connor] Right.
- We can give advice about
how to increase their chances
and how to help work the
algorithm, for example.
- But we're not gonna drop
a million dollar video idea,
'cause we would just do that.
- Yeah, there's no way that I can sit here
and guarantee you that
yes, I can give you advice
to make you a YouTuber that
gets a million subscribers.
Nobody can do that, or
an X amount from YouTube.
- As far as I'm concerned,
we were all very lucky in
that case as well, right?
We had the odds in our favor
- But nobody told us what to do.
- I mean, I preach by that, you know,
we did a lot of things right,
and we all were also very
lucky in a lot of aspects.
There wasn't one without the other.
There are things that you can
do to increase your chances
of success and massively
get the odds into your favor
but to guarantee something, to
guarantee success like that,
it's pretty much impossible.
- Yeah, I think the sad truth of life is,
and I think you just realize this,
is like I think the stock market
looks like a fucking casino
to many people.
- I thought it was a casino.
- A lot of the hedge funds
do treat it like such.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But at the end of the day-
- We learned that today, we
learned that in the past week
- At end of the day it's truly
a sad moment when you realize
there isn't really a get
rich quick scheme in life,
it doesn't exist, right?
And if you're looking for that,
I feel like you're already
setting yourself up
to be disappointed, or
gonna hurt yourself.
- If there was a scheme
that could 100% give you
a success rate of like,
you're gonna get famous,
you wouldn't think everybody
would be doing that?
- Yeah, it might make someone rich,
probably not gonna be you.
- Yeah.
(all laugh)
- Here's the thing, like
reading up about a lot of like
financial advice and everything
that I have for the past
you know, the past week,
like, take this with an exact-
(indistinct)
- Three people who don't know
what the fuck they're
talking about financial,
discuss financial advice.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Please do not take any of our advice,
this is not financial advice.
- We do have to make a
disclaimer about this
but from what I've read
and from what I've seen,
it seems like you can
definitely increase your chances
of being successful in life,
but the problem is that
a lot of the legitimate advice I've seen,
it seems to stem from
you don't get rich quick,
it's all boring stuff,
it's all put your money in safe places.
- It's the long game most of the time.
- Wait 10 to 20 years and
you'll be well off in life.
Nobody wants to hear that advice.
- That's just boring.
- That's just boring
- They wanna hear the,
I went to sleep, woke up
and I have a million dollars now right?
- You don't wanna hear about Roth IRA's,
or put your money in fucking cash Isis.
- I want Gamestop stocks.
- Yeah, exactly. They wanna
hear something exciting,
but when you hear boring financial advice
you just kind of tune out
and you're like, oh, okay,
so I can get rich but just not now,
but like in 10, 2O, no,
more like when I retire,
I'm gonna have a retirement fund.
- And thus Garnt figured
out why all the old people
hold all the wealth in nearly
every developed country.
'Cause I noticed, right?
I was just looking around for maybe like,
I wanted to just talk
to a financial advisor,
not like do anything, I
just wanted to talk to them
and just have like the free consultations
and talk to them,
and just figure out what the
fuck, like what do they do,
what can they do, what's a
good one, what's a bad one.
And I noticed on all of the websites,
at least in the UK,
every single one, right?
It was picture of some young
man helping an old person
out on a laptop, pointing at the monitor.
And then it was all-
- It's like a Stock image.
- Yeah, it was all just
like pension advice,
pension, pension, pension,
and like long-term, long-term.
Like none of it was like risky-
- For young people.
- Yeah, none of it was for young people,
'cause, you know, let's be honest,
young people don't do that shit.
- No, no. So yeah, it was really,
you kind of just like,
a lot of the things that
you'd noticed about the world
start to fall in place,
and when you start looking
you're like, ah, okay,
everything's starting to make sense now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like my best advice to
anyone young watching this,
is if this conversation leads to anything,
just go out and do your research.
Actually read up about this shit, because-
- Don't fucking sign up to a $500 seminar,
I will disown you.
- Don't do that, just read up
about basic financial advice.
- Everything you need to know is free.
- Yeah, that's the thing,
everything you need to know is free
and the only thing stopping
you is your own laziness.
Cause that is..
Me reading up about this
felt like I had just gained
five levels of info
that I should have known
when I was in my 20s.
And I'm just like, why didn't
I know this shit before?
I was stupid, I was lazy.
- Don't expect to get rich off
the GameStop stonks and shit,
like the road is gonna be long
and probably really boring.
- I'm investing in learning Japanese,
so that I can become a
translator for a yakuza
and then I'll translate the wrong number
like in the "Great Pretender",
and profit hundreds of
millions of dollars for myself.
Thus being the best investment of ever.
(all laughing)
- Well, someone's gonna take that idea.
- Don't fucking steal
my get rich quick idea,
I swear to God.
- You gave away the million dollar idea.
- Bi-lingual people
don't do it, all right?
- I'm just like writing it now.
- Joey's like shit, write that down.
Joey's called up his financial advisor.
I wanna set this scheme,
you won't believe it.
- Does anyone know any yakuza?
(all laughing)
- Any yakuza with cross
country gang information
that we could-
- Does any yakuza need any
translation work? I'm your man.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.
- All right, well boys,
I have something very
special planned today.
- Okay,
- They said it wouldn't happen,
the common said it couldn't
be done, but I finally did it.
I wrote a PowerPoint presentation.
(Joey laughing)
for all the different ways-
- You actually did it?
You actually did it.
- How many weeks ago was that?
- I was just like at week 10 or something.
- Yeah, like nine or something, right?
- That was just like,
you know, when you say
something off hand and then-
- It was an offhand comment.
- It was an offhand comment,
and then the community and the Reddit
were just like never let you forget
that you said that one thing.
- To explain what Garnt is talking about,
I don't know which episode it was.
Play the flashback mode on.
- What I gotta do is
I gotta, some episode,
I need to bring a presentation
of all the different ways
people have tried to hit on me.
Like, I gotta,
- Please.
- A PowerPoint presentation,
the most interesting ways it's happened.
So I made a little presentation,
with some fun images
to explain all the different
ways that you can be,
so I guess I should pull the laptop up.
- Are you about to break down the 93%?
- Break down the 93%,
it's not the 93% anymore,
it's like a 59%.
- This is how you can also be the 93%.
Sign up, first month is $100.
- I wanna preface that
this is not my laptop,
as it has stickers on it,
so it's just disgusting.
- [Joey] Yeah, that's my beautiful laptop.
- "A YouTuber Guide To Being Hit On,
all the ways a YouTuber can be hit on."
- Wow, this is bringing me
back to like high school.
- Dude, you've actually done
a PowerPoint presentation.
- I did.
- Is this is a Ted talk.
- This is my Ted talk,
Ted didn't invite me,
so I thought, we'll make my own.
- Before we start, how much
effort did you put into this?
- Not that much.
- Okay.
- So this is like...
Okay, so basically these
are all true things
that have happened at
one point or another.
And I didn't write the whole details out,
so basically they're more
prompts for my memory
to be like, ah yeah,
this is what happened,
all right, let me explain it.
- This looks like a real Ted talk.
- I guess so, yeah.
- This isn't like the high school,
I'm reading off the PowerPoint.
- No, there's literally like two sentences
just to remind me, oh,
it's this story, okay.
But yeah, I do wanna
preface before we begin,
I'm not trying to make
out that I'm some kind of
like fucking sex God
that no one can resist,
it's literally just when you
have X amount of subscribers
obviously there's gonna
be two people out there
that are stupid enough to
think that I'm attractive
and try and hit on me.
- Right.
- Okay,
- Just wanna get that out there.
- You're being very humble there.
- I do no think that I am
like X hot or whatever,
it just happens with the job, I think.
People don't try it with you,
'cause, you know, you guys are
basically married, all right.
Not to each other, of course.
(all laughing)
- Why are you laughing, Meilyne?
- Meilyne's like, I love the gay talk.
- She's like, tell me more
about how they're married.
- What do you expect to see on this list?
What are you excited for?
- Uh, I don't know.
Basically, I'm just looking
forward to this presentation
just being a massive excuse
to say I'm not a fuck boy but.
- No, I obviously didn't reciprocate,
'cause most of these are strange.
I've also accompanied, I just downloaded
a bunch of stock images, I
didn't pay for the license,
I shouldn't say that, but I
just downloaded the bunch.
- Thank you, Getty Images,
for sponsoring this episode.
- So just to accompany
it, just for fun, why not?
Like I said, I love Stock Images.
So we have the classic to
start with, what is that?
So this is, as I've said, a
text to my personal number.
- Okay, what? How did they
get your personal number?
- That's what I wanna
know, Garnt. I don't know
So this happened about, I
think four or five months
into my YouTube career, if you will.
I thought great, I
haven't leaked anything,
I just do live streams-
- That was what, 2015?
- Yeah, I was wondering how
the fuck someone had done this.
So turned out, at the time I had an iPhone
and the email that I listed
was actually like my email
linked to my iPhone account,
and someone had just
connected the dots of like,
Oh, let's just put this email
on my iPhone and text Connor.
I don't use iPhone anymore.
- Oh, that's how, because
they did the iMessage thing.
- Right, so I deleted that email,
so it doesn't exist anymore,
'cause I was like, fuck this.
But at the time it was very
creepy of wake up to a text
from an American number being like,
"Hi, is this Connor by the way?"
It's not exactly being hit on,
but I stopped it before
it could get there.
- Right.
- That's the first one, I
think this is a Stock Image.
- [Garnt] I've actually had
something similar happen to me.
- [Connor] Admire my Stock image.
- [Joey] I have a lot of
questions about this Stock image.
Why is there a potato there?
- [Garnt] What is that stock image?
- [Connor] I don't know, these
are all strange Stock images.
So she's just saying no
to the potato on the desk.
- But yeah, I've had
similar things happen to me,
I'm not gonna name what messaging app
or whatever it was on,
but I've realized that you
could find my username,
obviously pretty easily
through this messaging app.
And I would get like people adding me
and just messaging me randomly on it.
That was a humbling experience to realize,
oh, okay, I can't-
- I fucked up.
- Yeah, I fucked up,
I can't use this email for everything now.
- [Connor] All right,
the classy, the fan mail.
The actual handwritten letter
- Oh, like a physical fan mail.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Was this sent to your P.O box?
- This was sent to my P.O box, yeah.
- I was about to ask how
they found your address.
- P.O box, you know, had a few letters
that were asking if I was, you know,
'cause they would know what
conventions I'm going to
and then they would say,
"Hey, is it possible
that maybe we could go
on a date or something?"
And obviously, you know-
- I never got that,
even when I was single.
- No?
- Never.
- Maybe with time it'll change, Joey.
- Yeah.
- YouTubers weren't cool
back then, you know?
- Right.
- This is just like two, three years ago,
this used to happen.
It didn't happen that often,
but people would attach their
numbers and then they would-
- I never had that,
did you ever have that?
- I mean, when I first
started up really blowing up
on the anime community
I was already pretty much dating Sydney.
- Oh yeah, that's true.
- And, you know, if like Sydney makes her,
let's say she marks her territory.
- She wards off the-
- The laser eyes.
- The predators, also I added
a stock image, it's this one.
- [Joey] What is happening?
- [Connor] It's a guy with a beer.
- [Joey] This man's doing
like a parallel park drift
while pouring a beer, I guess.
- [Garnt] The classy.
- [Joey] On a highway?
- [Connor] And then this one
is the modern, the fan email.
Obviously, we get emails.
- [Joey] Yeah, we still get that.
- [Connor] It's a classic,
we get that all the time.
- [Garnt] That was a classic.
- [Connor] And then
this is the Stock Image,
'cause this is me putting
the emails in the trash
when you send them to me.
- I thought you meant
this is all the fan mails
we get for "Trash Taste".
(all exclaiming)
- I hate you, Joey,
it's not fucking funny,
- All pretty standard so
far for YouTubers though.
- Yeah. Okay, next we
have the extra classy.
I used to do Patreon fan letters,
where you could pay to
be pen pals with me.
- Okay, that sounds like so much effort.
- That doesn't sound like a
nightmare is about to happen.
- When I made that I
didn't think it was gonna,
so it's not on there anymore,
but I used to think that it was like,
oh, this is such a cool
way to connect with me,
and I didn't realize about the logistics.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- 'Cause you never do with Patreon,
you never think about the
logistics until you realize-
- I have do this every month.
- Yeah, basically I agreed to
write like 20 letters a month
which I'm not good at writing either,
and I don't like writing,
so writing one letter for me
takes like 30 minutes, cause I hate it.
- I've seen your handwriting.
- I hate writing so much
so it was just painful
and it was really frustrating as well,
I'll go on to how I got hit on after.
But it was frustrating as well
'cause people would join
Patreon for one month and leave.
So I would send out a letter
that would just be like,
"Hi, how are you? Nice to meet you,
tell me about yourself,"
and then not get a response.
But I'd have to write like
seven of those letters a month,
every month, and I was
doing them all by hand.
- How long was the letter itself?
- Like a page or two?
- Jesus.
- Geez, that's a long-
- For how much a month?
- I think it was on like the $40 tier,
but that was included with
a voice message as well.
- So like how much would,
let's let's break this down
on cost to effort-wise.
How much would it take you
to write a letter? Not long?
- I mean, I guess if they paid $40
for 30 minutes worth of work,
but I'd always get distracted
and I couldn't focus
'cause I just didn't wanna
be doing it, so it was awful.
But yeah, I had someone as
well, same with the fan letter,
who was like,
it was this really weird situation
where I'm not really sure what happened.
'Cause I was just being
like, ah, yeah, cool,
I like Pokemon too, I like these things,
'cause I was trying and be honest
and trying to make a friendship with them.
And then they were like, they
replied one time being like,
"Oh yeah, so I told my coworkers at work
that I have a boyfriend and
I said that it was you."
And then they asked like, "Is that okay?"
And I was like, sure, I don't give a fuck,
I'm not gonna go around
saying that, you can say that.
- She brings up the Cdawgva to YouTubers,
and she's like, "Hey, you
wanna see my boyfriend?"
- That's my boy right there.
- Look at that guy, Sebastian,
his name's Sebastian.
- I'm just thinking and
I'm like, is that a brag?
Because if they pull up my videos,
half of them are either
gonna be me reading BL,
or me in the cosplay.
And I think they were from
like Midwest somewhere,
super conservative state,
so I couldn't imagine
they would take too kindly
to me being like naked in
my room, basically going,
(squeals)
you know?
So yeah, that was
interesting, that was fun.
- Also, it's a boyfriend
that never fucking responds
to messages or anything like that.
It's a one way boyfriend.
- It's a boyfriend that
replies once a month via mail.
(Joey laughs)
But yeah, I ended up getting rid of that
because, just stuff like that-
- That sounds like effort.
- And also it's just way too much effort.
And this is the Stock
Image to accompany it.
- [Joey] What is happening?
(all laughing)
- [Connor] This is me
writing the reply email
to the hitman that they
hired if I didn't say yes,
that we were dating.
And then yeah, this is the obvious,
this is called nutting during fan calls.
I made a video about this,
you should go and watch it.
It's really old now.
- Yeah, I know the
story, but you can tell.
- So essentially there was this time
where I was doing a fan
call as Hetalia characters.
- That sounds like cringe
already, all right.
- So I was doing it with someone else
who was doing another voice,
and we were on the call with the person,
and I thought like there's
some weird breathing sounds
coming from them.
But I was like, huh, it
sounds a little weird
but I didn't think much of it.
- Was it Meyline?
(all laughing)
- Too bad, you bring the Dakimakura
or someone from like "Vampire
Knight" she'll get like that.
So what happened was, is
that we were on this call,
I thought, that's weird.
And then when we got off the call,
it was only like six, seven minutes,
I was like, "Bruce, was that weird?
That call was weird, right?"
And he was like, "Oh
no, I don't think so."
But I was editing the audio,
so I can go back and listen to the audio,
and I'm like, she's definitely nutting,
that isn't like hyperventilating breath,
it was like slow, deep breaths.
(breathing heavily)
Like that, and I was like, what the fuck?
So I made a video about it,
but I pitch shifted and changed it,
and it sounds even creepier.
It sounds like a two year
old now, which is just scary.
Because I wanted to protect
their identity obviously,
'cause I don't know if it was,
I don't know if it wasn't,
but like, it don't sound good.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But yeah, I had cut a lot of people-
- That's a bit of yikes.
- Yeah, that's a bit of yikes.
- How do you handle that?
- You're playing character, right?
When you do those calls
you're in character,
so when people would say stuff
I would reply in character,
like to reject them.
- I'd just like to imagine,
you just hear like,
(moaning)
And Connor's like pastor, oh yeah.
- Which "Hetalia"
character were you playing?
- I was playing France from "Hetalia".
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I've never watched
"Hetalia", but I assumed
he was like a bit of a player
from what I understood.
- I would have loved it if
he was playing like Italy,
and he was just like,
(moaning)
oh yeah, pastor, yeah.
- So I was playing France,
they were playing Italy.
- They were playing Italy.
(chuckling)
- Pastor.
(Joey moaning)
- This episode is sponsored
by EJ Anime Store.
- Kadokawa's official
online anime mode store
that specializes in delivering
the newest anime modes
to overseas anime fans
directly from Japan.
- Be sure to check out
the pre-order deadline
shown on-screen so you don't
miss out on today's item.
- What do we have for today's items?
- Look at all these beautiful items.
- Look at all that man.
What are you holding, Connor?
- I've recently just
become an art appraiser.
- Really?
- And I have to say,
I've added this piece to
my collection, gentlemen,
because it's a steal.
This wonderful piece here,
as I've been instructed
multiple times to pronounce
correctly by Meyline,
Is Sayakona, how to raise
a boring girlfriend,
(speaking in Japanese)
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Did I do it right?
- Obviously Connor is
a massive Sayakona fan.
- Woodblock print, now
as a big fan of the show,
I gotta say gentlemen, following...
(all laughing)
As a big fan of this I have to say,
following Megumi, and Eriri,
is that how you say it?
- Eriri.
- What a fucking tongue
twisting name, goddamn.
The third installment of, oh my God,
Sayakona ukiyo-e woodblock
prints series portraying utaha,
is finally here.
The wait is over. These
are brought to life
using Japanese craftsmanship techniques
originating in the 17th century.
Goddamn that is old.
And the background artwork
is actually connected
to all three illustrations
lined up next to each other
to form one large picture.
- Wow.
- Isn't that wonderful?
- And it looks beautiful.
- Is that part of the appraisal?
- It is.
- And we also got the Konosuba Mega Man
anime opening edition.
I mean look at how beautiful this is.
- That's actually one of the
dopest Mega man figurines,
I have a couple of Mega Men figurines,
this is easily the coolest one, yeah.
- This is Cara and his new
figure label, CA words,
bringing you this
beautiful konosuba figure
portraying Megaman unleashing
her explosion magic
while falling from the sky.
- I think you mean, explosion.
- I'm sorry.
- Fake fan.
- I'm a fake Konosuba fan.
- She can explode my wallet,
if you know what I mean,
with that figure,
- And this is recreating a scene
from the second anime opening sequence.
- We also got the Mushoku
Tensei jobless reincarnation,
Roxy Migurdia figurine right here,
which actually looks kind of dope.
- She does look dope.
- Love the base right there.
- We also got the (indistinct)
tea party version,
and we've also got the (indistinct)
wedding bikini version.
- That is Connor's favorite.
- Yeah, that is Connor's
favorite right there.
- You love that, right?
- Well, I do love it,
so I'm gonna go and check out these items
on ejanimestore.com while
they're still available,
or click the link in
the description below.
And if you haven't already,
follow them on Facebook
and Twitter, @EJanimestore,
so you don't miss their giveaways
and limited time offers.
Back to the episode.
- Woo!
- And like, to be fair, it
would happen fairly often
but I nearly always cut them
'cause it was just cringe.
And people would just be
like, I wanna date Sebastian,
and I'd be like, no one is
worthy of me, like that.
'Cause it's really,
like when I'm in the zone
and I would do these calls,
I would like fully believe in that moment
that I was like that,
'cause you have to if
you want to do it good.
- I mean, you're playing
a character, right?
- Yeah, so when people
would say stuff like that,
I would just like snarkily
just insult them straight away,
'cause they loved it.
- Yeah.
- And it was fun.
Dude, imagine being an asshole
and everyone's like, oh
my God, he's amazing.
- How long did you do this for?
- These calls?
- Yeah.
- I did them for like two, three years.
- How? Just how?
- No, 'cause when it went
well it was really fun,
because people had such a genuine,
happy response, really great.
- You had to just deal with
some weird shit fairy often.
And so I was like, all
right, I'ma head out
like this Stock Image,
from that call, am I right?
- I'm only joking Meilyne,
you were probably never that bad, right?
- No, she was. She still is, she is worse.
I'm joking.
(all laughing)
I've seen her when she
gets around Uta No Prince.
All right, next is the uncomfortable,
as if none of them were already.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- [Garnt] The last one
wasn't uncomfortable?
- No, I can deal with that.
- Okay.
- 'Cause that's in
character, that's not Connor,
that's Sebastian, that's France.
That's not my problem,
that's France's problem.
- She's getting real hot for France.
- So yeah, up until very recently
I used to do Patreon fan calls.
- That was not in character.
- No, as me.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I would offer, and
it's gonna sound like a lot,
for like $100 an hour
to have a call with me,
but then if you ask any
YouTubers around our sides,
they'll be like, wow, that's too little.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause, I know, it sounds
absurd, it sounds stupid,
my parents all thought it was dumb.
They were like,
"People pay to speak to
you, Connor? That's absurd."
- My parents got the same reaction.
- "Why would anyone wanna
pay speak to you, Connor?"
I'm like, mom, fuck off mom.
So anyway, up until recently I
used to do Patreon fan calls,
like I said.
I'd call it like generations,
I don't really know why.
but people would always leave
in mass and join in mass,
and there's only 10 spots on my call,
so only 10 people at a
time could get these calls.
And I would only maybe
have like one person
who was on it for like two plus years,
but the rest of the time it
was like rotating people.
And like I had some really
fucking uncomfortable ones
that I haven't really spoke about
'cause I'm just like,
this is so fucking weird,
but I mean, I might as
well speak about it now.
So this one time, this is by
far the most uncomfortable,
where I had done two calls with the person
and they were like, okay, all right,
they seemed pretty decent,
seemed pretty normal,
they were from Vegas,
you know? Aki represent.
- Yeah, I don't know why
you're pointing at me,
I'm not from Vegas.
- No, and they were like,
sorry, I didn't do webcam,
it was only about voice.
But one time they were
like, "Can we do webcam?"
And I was like, all right,
sure. I mean, a one-off, right?
Like what's the worst that
could happen with a webcam?
- Yeah.
- You guys know what happened.
- So I'm like okay,
sure. Sure, let's do it,
let's do webcam, whatever, you know,
you've been on Patreon for
a while, we can do this.
So we boot up the call,
I turn on my webcam,
she turns on her webcam.
Ah, yeah, she's naked. She's fully naked,
but wearing body paint, but you can like-
- The look on Usher's face.
- Oh my God.
- Luckily she was over
age, dodged a bullet.
- Thank God.
- Luckily.
- Luckily, thank God.
- Otherwise finna get
arrested immediately,
I was like, yo, what the fuck?
And then I was like, oh no,
the connection's breaking up,
and then like-
- You go like, hello can you hear me?
(imitating static)
- I was like, gosh.
- Hello, I'm going through a tunnel.
- Literally the moment it happened,
like it flashed on the screen,
I was like, smash the red
and fucking end this call.
I was like, fuck man.
You know how hard, British internet man,
it keeps going out.
I'm so mad at them man, ugh.
- I gotta stay on voice,
my internet can't handle the webcam.
- Damn, my webcam just imploded.
So I was like fuck, that's
awful, it's just terrible.
And I had some other
uncomfortable things come up
and generally just not
very good things happen,
that were just like,
why are they doing this?
Like, they would just hit on you
in really uncomfortable ways,
to the point where I
was just like, you know,
some people would think that, you know,
you'd meet some people who had
clearly never been rejected
in their circle, right?
And then they pay me to talk to me
and then they're like, well
I've never been rejected,
so it's not gonna start now obviously.
They think I'm gonna like...
This is a work thing for me,
I'm there doing business.
- It sounds like you had
a fucking babe station,
call center going on.
- Obviously, 'cause like, it's great,
90% of people, it was chill,
it was just talking to them,
give them a bit of useful advice,
and maybe help them with
things, super normal calls.
It's just like some people
were like, bro, this is my in,
this is my way to get Connor
to hang out with me or stuff,
and like all sorts of weird shit.
Like people would go around and,
like, I think recently, I used
to do like voice recordings,
I still do to be fair,
'cause they're really easy.
But people would go around,
take the voice recordings
and say, "Look, me and
Connor are best friends."
- Ugh.
- Like, I have a message
from Connor saying hi to me,
we're kind of like best friends.
And I'm like, do people know?
Like why do people do this?
Why? Do you think you're getting clout?
- Are you comfortable with that?
- Whatever.
- I wouldn't be comfortable with that,
I don't know that to me is-
- Someone going around saying
that they're a friend of mine
to get their way is not cool with me.
- I mean, it's also, you
know, it's big brain.
'Cause, you know, I could be like...
Let's say, right? God forbid,
I say something stupid on a live stream,
we're like, no, that's just a recording,
a Patreon recording not me.
What the fuck was that? No, I'm kidding.
- Well now when Connor
gets counseling, two year-
- When I get counseling
I'll be like guys no,
that was a script, I was doing a job.
- Just watch this one clip at least.
(all laughing)
- I'm kidding.
- I was playing France from
"Hetalia" the whole time.
- I never record anything inappropriate,
it's just like, obviously,
'cause some people want
an uplifting message
'cause they've been beaten down recently
and I'm more than happy to do that.
'Cause I'm like, you know, if
me giving you a voice message
saying, hey man, things will
get better, just keep trying-
- I mean, I've done that before as well,
but at the same time, if I
found out that that person was-
- Oh I don't give them
voice messages anymore.
- Yeah, was going around
telling people, hey-
- I'm best friends with Giggukaz
- I'm best friends with Garnt,
and I'm just like, okay, get
the fuck out of my life please.
- I email them basically saying,
hey, I'm removing you from Patreon,
what the fuck are you doing? This is sad.
- Yeah, of course. That's not cool.
- Because the worst thing was that
she wasn't going around
to like her close friends,
for some reason she was going around
and sending them to other YouTubers,
saying I'm friends with Connor,
look, I have this message,
and unfortunately some of
those YouTubers didn't know
that I was doing the
Patreon voice messages.
- But I mean, I've gone
through that as well
where I've had people going
around saying that they know me
and saying that they
have been friends with me
when they weren't just to try
and get in with other people.
And it's like, that's the
biggest fucking red flag for me.
- But that's kind of
one of the big reasons,
as well as time, is why
I removed the ability
to call me on Patreon,
I don't do it anymore.
You can't have a quick phone call with me.
- I think the worst
thing that happened to me
was it literally happened
to me at a convention,
where, you know, I had a
guy who was going around
telling people, telling
companies, that they knew me
and they were trying to use that as an in.
- That's somehow even worse,
is when they're going around to companies.
- 'Cause they're potentially
ruining your name.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- But they're also trying
to profit themselves, right?
- Yes, you see I can deal
with someone being a fucking
creep, that's (indistinct),
I can just immediately
shut that down, right?
But if someone does that,
that's repairing I have to do.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's horrible. Luckily, that's why-
- I guess that's why
it triggers me so much,
because I hear that and I just think,
dude, the shit I had to deal with then.
The audacity of this bitch.
- I would gladly have someone
hit on me on a call 100 times,
rather than them go to a company
saying that we're friends,
you know what I mean?
Cause I can, you know? That's fine.
- Don't do that.
- Dude, do not do that.
That is the biggest
asshole move you could do.
- [Connor] We have Garnt
in 50 years, as the-
- [Joey] It's (indistinct).
- [Connor] Okay, I don't
know what the Stock Image is.
- [Garnt] Where the fuck
did you get this image from?
- I don't know.
- What is this? Is this
like Asian Humpty Dumpty?
- You type in (indistinct),
and this what comes up.
- So this is, the real.
I was at a coffee shop one
time, in good old Swanzey,
and I'd recently just broke
up with my ex-girlfriend
at the time.
I was very sad and so my
housemates took me out for coffee.
And we were just like, you know,
he just wanted to talk to me
and just keep me uplifted, you know?
And I love coffee, I love talking,
so this is the perfect combination.
And whilst I was at the coffee shop,
dressed in like sweat pants,
miserable, some person,
what looked to be like a 15
year old girl, I shit you not,
by the way, I was like 20,
comes up to me and I know
they're coming to me.
You know how I know?
- [Garnt] How?
They got a fucking, they
have like the scout leader,
scout regiment backpack
from "Attack On Titan".
And I saw them looking at me,
and I could see this eye
contact not breaking,
coming up to me.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Right.
- And no joke, right?
She was like, can I sit down
and join you for coffee?
And she's like 15, and her
friend is like right there,
and I'm like, what is happening?
I think that's kinda inappropriate,
like, I don't really know you,
I don't really wanna do this.
I mean it's not really being
hit on 'cause underage,
but yeah, it was just
kind of uncomfortable
and just like what?
I thought like a picture, sure, okay,
I'm totally fine with doing pictures
or signing anything you want,
I don't care about that.
But like you wanna just sit down
and start talking next to me?
- Yeah, don't invite yourself
to like, that kind of thing.
- Yeah, I don't know, it's weird,
but they were a kid, they
didn't know any better.
- Yeah. I mean, that's
happened to us a few times,
I would think.
- It's happened at
conventions quite a bit.
- Yeah, it happens at conventions-
- Conventions, I expect it,
but when you're hanging
outside, just chilling,
and I was pretty beat up at
the time and I was really hurt.
- Yeah, you weren't in
the best mental state.
- I was really fucking sad,
and having a girl come up
to me, just being like,
hey, can I sit next to you?
I'm like, I really
don't want to right now.
- I don't wanna do anything
with any women anymore.
- It was literally like
the day off as well,
so I was like fuck it, I was miserable.
- Yeah, 'cause I think about that,
and I think, you know,
she'll probably look back
at that period of her life-
- Cringe.
- And just fucking cringe.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- 'Cause I can, we're not
saying you should do it,
or I'm justifying it or anything,
because you shouldn't do that.
But I know that, you know,
when you're that young
and you feel like you have
a para-social relationship,
you don't know about this stuff.
Especially, you don't know
about the social boundaries,
and she'll probably grow up
and she'll look back at that
and she'll wake up in a cold sweat.
And think, God, why
the fuck did I do that?
- Literally you can approach me anywhere,
even if it's in a fucking toilet,
I don't really give a shit,
as long as I'm not pissing,
or I'm eating or drinking.
- Yeah, please don't
do it when I'm pissing.
- While I'm pissing and
eating, just please don't.
'Cause I just wanna finish my meal,
it's what I look forward
to most in the day.
- It's the few times where
we can have full privacy,
so just give us that privacy.
- It's not even that, I
just wanna enjoy my meal.
I just love food so much, I
don't wanna have to think about,
oh fuck, I have to take a
picture, my steak's going cold.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, and this is the stock
image to go along with it.
- Quiet at a coffee shop.
You know how I told the
story about the dude
who stopped me in the urinal,
this is the exact face
he made when he saw me.
He was like, "Yo, it's
Joey!" I'm like dude-
- Like Joe, that's your dick?
- I'm like, dude, my dick's out man.
Like don't pog at me,
my dick's out right now man, let's stop
- He literally pog jumped your dick?
- I've mentioned the next story before,
but yeah, this is the hotel key card one,
when someone gave me their hotel key card.
- [Joey] Yeah, that
shit was fucking creepy.
- [Connor] This is the
Stock Image that I chose
to go along with it.
(Joey laughing)
- [Joey] What?
- Did you know actually,
this is the same trio-
- Is that Ludwig?
- No.
- Tell me that doesn't look like Ludwig?
- This is the girlfriend.
- This is the girlfriend meme, right?
- This is the girlfriend meme,
with the guy looking the other way.
- Oh.
- Yeah, I recognize the guy's face.
- It's the exact same
model, from the girlfriend.
- So yeah, to those who don't know
and don't wanna go back
and watch the episode,
essentially what happened
was someone gave me
a piece of paper and they
were like, this is for you,
and on it was their hotel
key card and room number,
that was signed.
And it said uh, there was
like times when I could go.
'Cause there was a person
at the desk next to me
who was helping, you know, manage,
'cause when you get the money,
you had to (indistinct).
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- And they were like, "Bro," and I'm like,
"Do you want it? I don't want it."
Needless to say, I immediately gave it
to the hotel reception when
I was done signing things,
and they were like,
"Why do you have this?"
And I'm like, it's a long story.
And this one's called, the
bold, it's a hotel door,
with a hotel door.
So I told you one story about
how there was one hotel room
where I was on the bottom floor,
and we came out and there was
the two girls, at midnight.
But there was another
time where I came back,
and this wasn't as creepy,
it was just kind of weird.
It was like middle of
the day, like 1:00 PM.
- Was this at an anime convention?
- This was at an anime,
of course it was an anime convention.
Where else would it be, Garnt?
So I don't know how someone
found out it was my room,
I was pretty careful.
Like I made sure, it
sounds so fucking stupid,
like made sure no one
was following me, right?
As Garnt should have.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- This is why I do it even
though it sounds like I'm CIA.
- I wouldn't have got it,
I wouldn't have understood
until I got followed back to my room.
- Yeah, I just don't want
people to know, right?
And there was just like, for some reason,
one girl who looked like
in her 30s, just like,
you know how the doorframe is like this,
just sitting like this at my doorframe,
like blocking the door.
- [Joey] What?
- And I was like-
- Well, like the door is here.
- Yes, so that's the frame,
- Okay.
- And this is the other frame.
- So they're just there
right in front of your door.
- Yeah, and I was like, hello?
And they were like, "Oh,
I like your videos."
And I'm like, oh no. I'm
like social skills 10,000,
I'm like, oh, no, no, no.
Then I was like , "Oh okay,
awesome. You want a picture?"
And they were like, "Yeah
sure, that'd be awesome."
And we took a picture,
and then they just left,
and I was like, cool, I
don't have to say anything.
All right, awesome.
'Cause I didn't know what was going on,
I was like, why are you in
front of my hotel room door?
We're on like the fifth floor
which is like nowhere near
the elevator or anything,
like this is really far away.
I think maybe they wanted, I
don't know if they knew me,
obviously they did,
but my first thought was like,
are they just chilling here?
'Cause I get it,
'cause sometimes the lobby
is really crowded and shit,
you wanna just go to
the alleyway or whatever
in the fucking rooms, 'cause they're long.
I was just like, oh, how did
you know this was my door?
That's pretty concerning,
I wanted to ask her.
I never found out, so
to this day I don't know
why she was in front of my door,
I don't know what she wanted.
Again, this isn't a very
good guys getting hit on,
this is just strange
ways people approach me.
- Yeah, this sounds like
a lot of strange things
that have happened about
you getting stalked.
- Just gonna say it's, hit on,
we're gonna put it all under
the umbrella, it sounds catchy.
- This is the YouTube clickbait,
we're gonna stay hit
on in the description.
- Yeah, this is actually
YouTube clickbait.
Yeah, this is true.
And then this is the Stock image
that I found for this one.
Although there is that one story-
- [Garnt] R.I.P to all
the audio only listeners.
- This does make me
realize about the person
who isn't on the list,
but the person who named
their baby after me
Have we told that story?
- Oh yeah.
- We haven't told that story.
- So back when I was re-doing
"Black Butler" a lot,
there was this one person
who, obviously this was it,
that's how I remember,
I just remembered the
canonical in my head.
I went to the "Black
Butler" meetup one time-
- The canonical order.
- The canonical order of the-
- This is head canon.
- They say in the filler arc.
- So what happened was, this
was like my first ever AIX,
and I can't remember how
long I was doing YouTube for,
but I thought it would be cool just to go
to the "Black Butler" meetup
and just say hi, hey man,
I'm the guy on YouTube
who does all the "Black
Butler" stuff, right?
And just say hi and just, you
know, it was just to meet them
and just meet all the fans of
"Black Butler" and to be like,
yeah, this is fucking sick,
and they're all really nice.
And there's one person who
was like really, really nice,
super, super nice.
And yeah, she was really nice,
we got loads of pictures
with her, a little intense,
but that's fine, I'm used to that.
- I mean all "Black Butler"
fans are quite intense,
to be fair.
- Yeah, but some of them are just there,
don't give a shit about
watching my videos,
but there was a good... I'd
say like half there were like,
oh my God, yo, excuse me.
- 'Cause you were the "Black Butler" guy
back then, weren't you?
- I mean yeah, in terms of
YouTube I was the only one
making content about "Black Butler".
- 'Cause it was like how many years after
"Black Butler" had aired?
- Yeah, I feel like I almost
made like a mini renaissance
of the (indistinct), in terms of Western.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause the community
became way more active-
- It's kinda like what
the "Abridged" series,
did for the "Yu-Gi-Oh"
anime back in the day.
- I mean, I don't wanna
say it was that heavy
but I feel like it was definitely a bump
because of all the "Black
Butler" stuff I was pumping out.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But anyway, a year goes by, right?
And I go to the, you
know, they're messaging me
telling me you have to come back
to the "Black Butler" meet up again,
I have a big surprise for you.
And so I'm like, all right, okay, sure.
I thought it was like a gift or something,
that they were making out to me.
So I was like, okay, sure, I'll
get it, I'll take a picture,
I'll come, why not?
This is the point where I was trying
to distance myself from "Black Butler",
but I was like, okay, cool, I'll come.
And so I go, lo and behold
she's holding a baby,
literally, like a two month old baby.
I don't know how old this baby
is, like it's a fresh baby.
- Fresh baby.
- Fresh out the oven.
- Freshly made baby.
- Not a single wrinkle on this baby.
And she's like, "Do
you wanna hold Connor?"
I'm like, "Connor? That's
a funny coincidence."
And she said, "Oh no, no,
it's not a coincidence,
I named him after you."
And I'm like, okay, this is fucking weird.
This is fucking weird.
- The fuck? My favorite ever photo
is of you holding baby Connor.
- It's still out there?
- With the most uncomfortable smile
I've ever seen on you.
- How'd you even react to that?
- Uh, just pure confusion.
And again, you gotta understand Garnt,
I just go with everything.
- His face holding the baby is like,
- I mean, yeah, I get it. I
would do exactly the same thing.
- I wanted the picture to
reflect how uncomfortable I was
so I could tell the story later on.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- Yes, there's a picture out there.
If you just Google,
Connor with baby, maybe?
I don't fucking know.
- Connor with baby?
- Cdawg baby I don't fucking know.
Well I don't know what the fuck comes up.
- It's CDawgVA two.
- Yeah, and to be fair,
it's pretty fucking cute,
but like there was something
wholly uncomfortable
about holding a stranger's baby
that I just, I don't know,
it's like holding someone's
expensive vase, you know.
- I still don't know how to handle babies.
Like someone asks me if
I wanna hold their baby,
and I'm just like, does it come
with an instruction manual?
What do I do?
I feel so inadequate when
it comes to handling babies.
- They're great for the 10 seconds
where they're not like crying,
and then the moment you pick
them up and they start crying,
I'm like, Oh God, Oh God, what to do?
- It's like stop please,
please, stop, stop!
- Yeah, but as odd as that is,
and almost creepy, you could say,
it's flattering more
than anything, I guess.
- I mean, don't get me wrong.
- They were very nice.
- It's probably flattering in a sense but-
- It's flattering, I
just, I would feel that
if anyone named a baby after me,
that's a bit too pressure on me.
- I feel like naming your
baby after any influencer
is a bad idea.
- Did you find it Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] Yeah.
- What did you type in?
- [Meilyne] Cdawg baby.
(all laugh)
- Type in Cdawg baby.
- Okay, Meilyne found it
by typing in, CDawg baby.
- Apparently it comes up.
- I just think it's a bad idea
naming your baby after any influencer.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- We all know we're just one
bad tool away from being-
- Yeah, don't name your kid
after your favorite
YouTuber, that's weird.
- It's like getting a tattoo
of your favorite YouTuber, right?
- But luckily it was just
Connor and not CDawgVA the bay.
- Yeah, I have no idea
how Corp's husband feels
when he sees his voice,
what do we call it?
- It's his wave file.
- Yeah, the wave form of
him breathing as a tattoo.
I'm just like, man, how'd you handle that?
- Yikers.
- Yeah.
- So that's how that happened.
- Yeah, that is very bold indeed.
- That is very bold.
- I've got like the next one,
it's called, the smooth paper.
I've been handed pieces of the
paper before at conventions,
you know, I always like sign something,
or I'll take a picture and
I'll charm in a piece of paper.
I'll be like, "Hey, here's
my number? Come text me."
I think that's kind of
smooth, that's very old style,
I don't know why that's smooth.
I never reply to any of
them, 'cause I'm like, bro,
my phone doesn't work in the U.S,
sorry, I just have internet.
But it's very smooth, I like it,
I actually like that
one, I think it's classy.
- Now, you're gonna get
this at every convention.
- No, shit. Fuck, I shouldn't have said.
'Cause with this one, it's not intense,
it's like, if I wanna
call you, I'll call you.
I'm not gonna call you,
just letting you know,
because I'm too fucking busy.
- It's just the casual, right?
That's how I imagine people-
- It's nice.
- Yeah.
- There's something simple
about it that's so inoffensive.
But maybe it's because I'm a guy,
I feel like if I was a girl
and guys kept doing it to me,
I'd be annoyed.
- Yeah, that'd be very creepy.
- Yeah.
- It is very flattering
when someone is attractive
and they send you, you
know, they hit on you.
It's like, oh wow, this league? Really?
Ah, no, get out of here.
- We weren't even playing the same sport.
- I thought I was playing checkers,
you're playing 40 chairs.
(all laughing)
This don't match.
But yeah, I mean, it's a nice
ego boost for like 20 minutes
until you realize that-
- Until you realize it's a bit weird.
- Until you realize, fuck, this
is a bit strange, isn't it?
Golden rule, don't fuck your fans, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Especially in this climate,
I just think that's a
great rule to stick by.
- Yeah, dude. Whenever I used to...
'Cause for the first like
two or three months in Japan,
I had like Tinder, 'cause I thought
no one's gonna recognize
me on Tinder, fantastic.
But yet there's people who
recognized me on Tinder here
who could speak English obviously,
and obviously a white guy would stand out.
And they were like, oh,
I watch your videos,
I'm like, immediately unmatch.
- Honestly, like-
- You played it smart.
- Why would I wanna...
I don't want to date someone
who turns up and they're like,
yo, I love that video you just posted.
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa.
- Because unfortunately
there's a lot of YouTubers
who'd probably use that
as an ego boost, right?
- Yeah.
- Listen, okay, getting in the whole topic
of fucking your fans, or dating your fans.
There is a way to go about it that works.
- There is a right way
and there is definitely a wrong way.
- Dunky and Leah, they
met through being fans,
and no one ever would
question, what's the word?
- Legitimacy?
- The legitimacy or the
ethicacy of that, right?
That's a legitimate relationship.
But there are ways to doing it
that are like taking
advantage of your power,
and I think that's where
people have the problem.
And unfortunately, a lot of
YouTubers don't understand
when they are kind of taking
advantage of their own power
in the situation.
- Yeah, I feel like hooking up,
I say hooking up, hooking
up is the wrong word.
Because if hooking up
with your fans implies
that yeah, you are just kind of just like-
- You're not pursuing
anything afterwards, right?
- You're just kinda
throwing your fame out there
and everything like that.
And I feel like you have
to be really self-conscious
about this, and I'm glad that people
are looking more into this,
and putting more attention into this.
- Fans are getting
smarter about it as well.
- Yeah, and fans are getting
smarter about this as well,
as they really should be.
And it's the responsibility
you hold as a YouTuber,
and sometimes you just don't
wanna worry about that.
You just wanna meet someone
where you don't wanna have to worry
about this power imbalance
because we all are just people as well.
We're all just people and sometimes
we just wanna switch off
this part of our lives,
and just be a normal fucking
person like anyone else.
- Yeah.
- I don't want someone
who watches my videos
and has an expectation
of me in general, that
I couldn't live up to.
- That is portrayed through your video.
- Right.
- It's funny 'cause most
of the friends I've made
who started off as fans,
as we became friends
they just started watching
less and less of my stuff.
And that's because...
In a lot of ways that
made me more comfortable,
or we stopped talking about it
because they were just mates
and we would talk like mates,
and talk about whatever
else apart from my job,
as I'm sure they stopped-
- I kinda feel that works in the same way
with like friends between
two YouTubers, right?
It's like, I definitely watched less
of my YouTuber friends
videos after we just kind of
went past that point
and just became friends.
- No, you keep up with it
just to see what your mates are doing.
- Yeah, but you're not like damn bro,
that last video, fucking banger bro.
Like I would've done
this differently though.
- Like I like showing support
to my mates, you know?
But it's different from being like,
yo I'm a huge fan of
what you did, fuck yes,
fucking banger right there.
- Yeah, man, life's hard hey.
If you're a YouTuber, if
you wanna just be safe,
don't fuck your fans.
- Rule number one, don't fuck your fans.
- That's what I've been doing
and it's been working good for me.
- Don't fuck your fans.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
Here's my Stock Image.
- [Joey] Can you explain why you chose
this particular image?
- [Garnt] Okay, so there is a Labrador
holding a gun right now.
- [Connor] I don't know,
I just thought this one was fun, you know?
- [Joey] Okay, sure.
- [Connor] I don't know,
it's kind of fun, right?
- This is what happens when you reach
like the end of your project
and you're just like,
I'll just throw whatever shit I put on.
- Well, we're about halfway.
- We're about halfway? Okay.
- The next one started
getting a bit more obvious,
you've ever been hit on on
the YouTube comment section?
- [Joey] Of course, yes.
- [Garnt] Of course.
- [Connor] Yeah, of course.
"Take me on a date next time
I visit Japan," that happens.
- [Garnt] Yeah, that happens a lot.
- I got a few of those
comments and it's like, uh, no.
How about you pay for my date?
- Yeah.
- I wonder if anyone has, ever
in the history of YouTube,
probably has, would have taken
a comment like that seriously
and tried to pursue it.
- I mean, if you're like
a smaller YouTuber, maybe
- For a YouTuber, yeah.
I mean I did something
similar along with email,
somebody emailed me asking
me to go on a date and-
- Yeah, but there's a
difference between an email
and a YouTube comment.
- Yeah, true.
- Anyone can write a YouTube comment.
- The live, and then obviously, you know,
people ask you on dates on
livestreams all the time.
You're streaming, yeah,
I get comments sometimes
being like, can we on a
date, can we go in Japan?
People subtly ask questions that are like,
I think they that they're being subtle,
but it's very obvious what they're asking.
Like for example, one very big giveaway,
as to what some people
are asking are like,
"Hey, would you ever do
like long distance
relationships by the way?"
And like, some people might
genuinely be curious, right?
But there's a way that
certain people ask it,
that is like, no.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It kind of gives you that vibe of like,
you're asking this for a purpose.
And also I get a donation sometimes,
which I think that's another one actually,
but where people will be
like, oh, I'm just wondering,
what kind of age group do you go for?
If it isn't obvious by now, uh, MILFs.
(Joey laughing)
Mother knows best, that's what I go for.
- All the MILFs rise up right now.
- So, you know, if you're around my age-
- Lonely housewives, this
is your time to shine.
- They're preparing their
wallets for the next stream.
- If your husband is not cutting it,
I don't wanna know who he is, but...
(all laughing)
I'm kidding.
Yeah, I mean, stuff like
that. What else do I get?
There's ones as well,
you know what I get asked a fair amount,
which is like the least subtle?
Which is like, would you ever date someone
who like, doesn't do YouTube?
And I'm like, do you think I
exclusively date psychopaths?
Like, is that what you think?
- No, I only, exclusively, date YouTubers.
- That's weird.
- If you don't have at least 10,000 subs-
- Well, you guys date YouTubers,
but I couldn't imagine dating a YouTuber.
- I mean, I started dating her
when she had like less than 1000 subs,
so it's a little bit different.
- I mean, I convinced my
girl to become a YouTuber.
- So you brought them into the play.
- Yeah, we brought them in, yeah.
- I wouldn't want my significant
other to be a YouTuber.
- Why?
- I don't know, I don't wanna
fucking deal with another me,
that's fucking awful.
And like, my schedule
is such a mess already,
that I wouldn't...
Like a relationship, to me,
like that would be such a fucking mess
if both of us had similar
schedules like that.
- I mean, I don't blame you.
There's lots of people who are like that.
- That's just me, it's just
me, that's what I want.
- Yeah, I feel that's just how
our relationships ended up.
- Yeah, true.
- I mean, it's just a
standard work schedule.
- [Connor] And like this
Stock image, which is a...
- [Joey] Again, it doesn't
really have anything
to do with the point but
is a funny Stock image.
- [Connor] Oh no, no,
I just wanted to put a
Stock image in there.
This one, donations again.
- [Garnt] The charitable.
I'm pretty sure these
are called simps, right?
- [Connor] These are called uh...
- [Joey] But you can't say that anymore.
- [Garnt] Oh yeah, banned off Twitch.
- No, learn to call them, prime members.
- T3 subs.
- You're a prime member, well,
we're going on a date soon.
Yeah, obviously, you get that a lot.
Actually, Instagram, message requests,
I get that a lot.
- [Garnt] Do you actually check them?
- No, 'cause I used to-
- I do every now and then just 'cause-
- I used to.
- Yeah, I used to as well
and then I realized that these are useless
and I stopped checking it.
- Yeah, it's like throwing
a coin down a well
hoping for it to grow into a tree, right?
It's like, it's not gonna happen.
But yeah, this is the Stock
image to go along with it.
I don't really know-
- [Joey] What is happening there?
- [Connor] They're on a car bonnet.
- [Joey] Definitely having sex.
- [Connor] I'm not really
sure what's going on.
- [Garnt] I have no idea
what's going on there.
- Yeah, so that's Instagram
messages, completely useless.
Don't do it, it's not gonna work,
unless you have a shit ton of followers.
I think it pops up, Instagram tells you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah .
- Someone big has messaged you.
- There's like some kind of
threshold of followers, right?
- Yeah.
- It's like having that
blue tick mark on Twitter.
- True.
I already mentioned this
one, but just Tinder.
- [Joey] Yep.
- [Garnt] Yep.
- [Joey] Wait is that the same girl
in front of the burning house?
- [Connor] It does look
like her, doesn't it?
- [Joey] It looks like her, doesn't it?
- [Garnt] Oh yeah, it kinda does, yeah.
- [Connor] Could be.
- [Joey] It could be.
- Maybe she found a nice career
in Stock images afterwards.
- Who knows?
Also, actually, believe it or not,
I've been hit on on Fiverr.
- [Joey] Of course you have.
- [Connor] No joke.
- [Joey] Of course you have,
why am I not surprised?
- I legitimately had a seller-
- Sell your services, is that it?
- 'Services'.
- They were like, "Connor,
I've got a great deal for you,
let me give you a custom offer on Fiverr."
So yeah, actually, funny enough
they were really a good
sport about it though,
but they were basically
just kind of like...
I think I had hired them
for one of the videos,
and I think they were an artist.
- What were they trying to buy from you?
- No, I hired them, and then
when the video came out,
they were like, "Oh, thanks
for including me in the video."
But I don't know if you wanna
ever just call or hang out.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- Here's my discord, and I'm
like, oh, okay, all right.
- This man's an absolute chick magnet.
- No, this is what I'm saying, right?
When you have, you know...
How many fucking views do we
get a month on our channel?
Like eight, nine million
views a month, right?
All it takes is one person
to think I'm attractive.
Why? I don't know,
to then go on and then
do something, right?
I don't think I'm
inherently more attractive
than anyone or most people,
you just have a platform.
- But the thing is like,
I've never experienced that,
and I don't think Garnt's
ever experienced that.
- Really?
- Well, not to this-
- But, to be fair, I also-
- But also I feel like your content-
- Yeah, I do videos
about dating and stuff.
- Yeah, I mean, it doesn't surprise me.
- I guess you do appeal
more to that kind of crowd.
- Anyone who has, 'cause
a lot of your content base
started off with literal fan interaction.
- Yeah, it all started from there.
- Whereas or me, I literally didn't start,
even for most of my videos,
I don't show my face
on my videos at all.
- Whereas we don't give
a shit about our fans.
No, I'm just kidding.
- Yeah, you don't, you fucking scum.
My whole YouTube career in the start
was built off interaction, and
I'm very grateful for that.
- Which is why it doesn't surprise me,
why some of the weirdest fan interactions
have come from you.
- I guess so. Yeah, that makes sense.
- If you give avenues
for people to talk to you
they'll find a way to hit on you,
that's how it works.
Now, this is the Stock image.
- [Joey] Oh my God, what is that?
That was me at the end of
the figurine challenge,
that's what it felt like.
- [Connor] True, I was just wondering
what the direction was here.
I don't know, I'm curious.
- Hey kid, swallow this
fish for us real quick.
He said, all right, I got you fam.
- Viking kids eating a meal.
- How much am I getting, $5 for this?
- I've been asked out if
I'd like to go drinking
with someone at a panel.
- [Garnt] In front of other people?
- [Connor] In front of the whole panel.
- Yeah, I've had that.
- Like two women, who were, I guess,
in my preferred
demographic of older women.
Who were like, would you like to-
(Garnt laughing)
- Connor was like, I'm listening.
- I was like, you have my attention.
- Connor goes through his analytics,
and he picks by demographic.
He's just like, get rid of all this,
this is like 25 to 30, no, none of that,
too close an age.
- 35 to 45, ooh.
- Ooh, okay.
- So legit, I think it
was two women, right?
I think one was the aunt
and one was the mother
of the daughter they brought along.
And she just sticks her
hand up and she's like,
"I have no idea who you
are but I like your voice.
Would you be willing to
have drinks with us later?"
- The mom said that?
- The mum said that, and
I've never seen a child
go from like smiling to anger so fast.
The child's like, mom, mom, mom!
- The child's like, I was gonna say that.
- I was just like, yeah,
I'd love to, jokingly.
I never did.
Honestly, if they came up me afterwards,
- Of course you would.
- Or found me at the bar,
I'd have been like...
I love talking, I don't know,
moms are so fun to talk
to at anime conventions.
No, not in the hitting
on way, just in general.
They're so fun, dude,
'cause they don't give a fuck
and they're like, "I don't know
what the fuck is happening,
but I'm the cool parent
that was willing to come
to the anime convention.
- To be fair, it's at a signing,
and a mom or a dad comes
with their son or daughter,
- They're always so chill.
- And they're like... Yeah,
they're the best people also.
- Honestly, they are pretty chill.
- See? Meilyne is trying
to make it creepy.
It's not fucking creepy, Meilyne.
- It's 'cause you specifically said moms.
I love talking to parents at conventions.
- I'm just like dads, no, no, no.
I'm kidding.
- Give me all the moms.
- No, no, no, I've had like a...
Oh wait, I don't know
if it comes up later.
I'll tell it later,
but basically there was this
one guy I've had before,
like his kids really
liked me and he was like,
oh yeah, can I buy you
dinner or something?
I'm like, yeah, fucking sure, why not?
I'll talk to you, we'll
hang out and be nice.
And it was nice getting
to know him and his kids,
so that was cool.
- Yeah, I've had the same
things with dads as well.
- They're just cool, man.
- If a dad's willing to
get involved in this shit,
then they're a cool fucking dad.
- [Joey] Yeah, absolutely.
- When that happens and they show passion
about what their kid is passionate about,
I think that's so fucking cool.
- That's a good parent.
- I wish my parents did that,
'cause my parents didn't do that,
and they would never do that to this day.
- I think the proudest mom I've ever seen,
it was at AIX and we had signings,
and then two little kids come
and, you know, they were cute and stuff.
And then the mum looks at me
and she like sees my name and everything,
and she goes, asked me
in Thai, "Are you Thai?"
Then I reply in Thai and then
we have this conversation,
and she was just like,
I am so fucking happy
that my kids are looking
up to a Thai person.
Thank you for representing
the Thai people,
I am proud of you, thank you very much.
- I had the opposite once in Finland,
where the mum was a big fan
and the daughter had no idea.
Like the mom came up and was
like, "Can you sign this?"
- God, I wish that was me.
(all laughing)
She was like, "Can you sign this?"
And I was like, yeah, sure,
and I looked at the daughter
and I was like, okay, what's your name?
I looked at the daughter and
I was like, what's your name?
And the mom was like,
"No, no, no, it's me."
And I was like, Oh okay.
- Cause I feel like for
Southeast Asian parents, right?
Anytime you talk to a
Southeast Asian parent,
whenever you meet someone
else who is the same race,
every Southeast Asian mother especially,
they go into Southeast Asian mum mode.
- Yeah.
- So the first thing she legit asks me
after finding out I'm
Thai and just, you know,
asking the basic questions,
is have you had any Thai
food recently? 'Cause I can-
- You've gotta eat good Thai food, right?
- Yeah, you gotta have good Thai food,
I could recommend you some places
if you're missing some Thai food.
I'm just like, dude,
honestly I'm like, thank you so much.
I'm going to take this advice to heart.
'Cause honestly yes, I
am missing Thai food.
I am missing home.
- 'Cause also like moms or
like parents have come up to me
and are like, do you want a water?
You look like you're tired.
I'm like, thank you, I'll take this.
Thank you, that's so kind.
- I've had a dad just slip me a $20,
being like, buy yourself
a beer after this,
you're working real hard today, son.
I'm like, thanks man.
- I had one time similar to that
but there is, actually, an
old Patreon of mine met me
and her grandma came,
and she must have been
like 78, I'm not sure,
and she was just so impressed
that I wrote in cursive.
She was like, in the most hick,
not hick, it was kinda like Midwestern,
kind of like, "Oh, you
know, it's just not right.
They teach the kids here,
they don't teach them
how to write cursive.
It's not right, I really like that
that you keep the old ways alive."
And I'm like, I'm just British.
I have no fucking clue
what you guys are doing.
I'm like, I don't know if it's that good
because no one can read
my fucking handwriting.
So, I mean, honestly,
what your kid's doing
is probably already pretty good actually.
Yeah, also the Stock image,
I actually found one that
was fitting for this.
- Oh yeah?
(all laughing)
- [Connor] Pregnant lady with a gun.
- [Joey] With the tiniest
gun I've ever seen.
- [Connor] That's like a...
- [Joey] That's like a BB gun.
- [Connor] That's like a German pistol,
like World War Two, that looks like
- [Joey] That's like the spy gun
that they like hide in a purse, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, is this a scene
from like "Inglorious
Bastards" or something?
- [Connor] This is
definitely a frame taken
from a Quentin Tarantino movie
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Connor] Uh, fuck, oh yeah.
This wasn't so much odd.
This wasn't being hit on but
this is just a funny story
I wanted to tell.
So one time I was at a convention,
and I actually have this
guy on Facebook still,
so he's really nice.
But it was very strange
and things kept adding on
and adding on,
where I went to it and
they were like, okay...
When you go to a convention as a guest,
typically if it's a big convention,
you'll get like a handler.
- It's like an assistant.
- Yeah, basically someone who makes sure
that you turn up to your
appointments on time,
and also if you need anything,
or like let's say you're signing things,
and you run out of sharpies.
Like, can you give me a sharpy real quick?
They'll do stuff like that.
And the guy I had, he was like,
"Oh yeah, my daughter's a big fan."
I'm like, cool, cool that's awesome.
He's like, "Would you
mind saying hi to her?"
And I'm like, yeah, of course, of course,
like I'll hang out with him.
And then he was really nice
and he helped me out a lot,
he always got me whatever I needed.
And then he was like,
"Yeah, do you wanna come
for a family dinner
with me and my family?"
I was like, oh, okay.
I mean, I felt like I had to say yes,
but I was like, oh sure,
of course, I don't mind.
- I mean, this guy's
helping you out right?
- Yeah. I mean, I literally
had nothing better to do,
and I was like, yeah sure, why
not? You've been real nice,
so I'd love to meet your family.
His family was like 12 kids or something.
- Jesus Christ.
- Half of them knew who I was,
and half of them didn't care,
but it was like being in the middle of,
was it "Half A Dozen"?
What's that movie called?
What the fuck is that family movie called?
- I know what you're talking about.
- Yeah.
- By the dozen, or something like that.
- Something like that.
But it was really cool 'cause
I think he was a foster parent
or something and it was really cool,
the story was really unique.
Not being hit on by the way,
at all, quite the opposite,
I just thought it's a cool story to tell.
I just thought it was really odd
that I got like roped into this,
and I was like, what is happening?
Why is there 12 kids?
- All I can envision is
that seen from "Annie",
where they're all eating
on the really long table
and you're just in the middle.
- Yeah, I'm in the middle of these 12 kids
and I felt bad 'cause the
dad was trying to talk to me,
but obviously all the kids were like,
"Yo, it's the YouTuber!"
They wanted my attention,
and he kept asking me questions,
and they could be like,
"Do you pay taxes?"
Or something like that,
and I'm like, well-
- A four year old asking you is like,
are you avoiding taxes?
- Are you the IRS? Kids, no.
Yeah, it was just really cool,
I felt it was a fun story.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Oh God.
- [Connor] Well, that was
just a morbid Stock image.
- [Garnt] This is a hell of a Stock image.
- [Connor] I don't know why
this was the Stock image.
- [Joey] Getty, why do you have this?
- Sometimes you just look at Stock images
and you think in what context
would someone want to use this?
- What was the direction they had when-
- Honestly, I do think there
is like a small market,
a small market of Stock
Image photographers
that are like, I'm hoping
this is gonna become a meme.
I'm betting that this, I'm
gonna take some meme photos
and hope that this becomes-
- They're all racing to
be the next meme, right?
- To become the next
jealous girlfriend meme guy,
this is definitely giving
me that energy right now.
- Yeah. For sure.
- All right, this is the
unexpected, if you will.
Let me show you the
Stock image first of all,
I have a good stock image.
- [Joey] Now that's a
Tarantino shot right there.
- [Connor] My cigar with the
boys, we kidnapped somebody.
So one time, like you said,
the daughters bring their mothers along.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And one time they were
both really big fans,
and I thought, well
that's so fucking cool.
And yeah, I didn't
really think much of it,
like she was joking, being like
she said I looked like Tom cruise,
and I'm like, I do not
look like Tom cruise,
I look quite the opposite of Tom cruise.
- Is this basically every Reddit post
who has like a white guy with a beard,
and they're like that looks
like Connor, that guy.
- Oh yeah, that's Connor man,
the white beard checks out.
And then I was, oh okay,
and then they were like,
are you're seeing anyone?
Like legit asked me this.
- Wait, the mom was on you?
- Yeah, the mom asked me that
while I'm signing the
daughter's autograph.
And I thought, Oh, not really.
She was like, "Oh, okay, do
you wanna get a drink later?"
And I'm like, ah,
and I was like, yeah, sure, sure, sure,
thinking like this isn't serious.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Found out later she was very serious,
and she was very disappointed
that we didn't have that drink.
'Cause I thought it was joking.
- You basically stood her up.
- You stood up a MILF, Connor?
- I'm not proud to say it.
- The world is gonna end tomorrow.
- I'm not proud to say, but yeah I did.
- Connor, I had expected better from you.
- I believe it was a single
mother as well, actually.
- Oh, that's like your fantasy
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
The thing with MILF porn, right?
You see, you don't see the kids,
so that's a big plus, right?
I don't wanna fucking know about the kids,
don't tell me about the kids,
I don't wanna get involved.
What's wrong Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] So what if they call,
if you get married and
they have to call you dad?
(Connor exclaiming)
- That's so gross.
- I mean, some people are
into the daddy thing, right?
- No, it's the fantasy.
Listen, the problem with the
whole MILF dynamic in real life
is there are a lot of hurdles
that make it very
uncomfortable and very awkward.
- I would feel so sorry
for the fucking daughter.
Imagine being a fan-
- I felt sorry for the daughter as well.
- Imagine being a fan of a YouTuber
and then they become your dad,
let's just think about that for a second.
- That is like a visual
novel in the making.
- Yeah.
- He was my favorite
YouTuber, but now he's my dad?
But actually it was the daughter
that ended up being like, oh, I'm sorry,
my mom just gets carried away sometimes.
And I'm like, your mom's on the
prowl next to you, with her?
What's going on?
What kind of dynamic are you guys using?
- Your mom's in cougar mode.
- You guys are real close
to be like scouting out
the prey with each other,
you know what I mean?
- Her mom's like, yo, become my wing-woman
- That's what it was, it was
like a wing-man. It was crazy.
- That's nuts.
- [Meilyne] Domestic boyfriend.
- Domestic boyfriend.
- It's like love triangles,
you know, in a porno or a hentai,
it's very attractive in the hentai,
but you realize in real
life, fuck, it's a nightmare.
- Yeah, it's messy as fuck.
- If you have anything like
that, it never ends well.
- And that was definitely
unexpected, that's for sure.
- That was the unexpected.
I actually got hit on,
on "Overwatch" one time.
- [Joey] Oh yeah?
- That was fun.
- [Joey] How so?
- Oh, someone recognized who
I was and then I added them,
I started playing with them,
and then just casually started inquiring
about my love life and
stuff, and that's normal.
- Were they like role playing
or anything like that?
(indistinct)
- At which part of your
career was this in?
- Which part of the career?
When did "Overwatch" come out?
It was like literally three four months
into "Overwatch" being released.
- Oh, okay.
- Oh yeah.
- That was a while ago then.
- That was like four or five years ago?
- Yikes, I'm old.
Whenever "Overwatch"
came out, this happened,
yeah, I remember it
just being a bit awkward
because they kept asking,
like when someone normally
inquires about your love life
an a bit of uncomfortable amount
when you don't really
know them, which is fine,
I mean you can ask me about
that, I'm pretty open about it,
I never mind talking about it.
But then when you proceed
to ask me the next step,
it's like you live in Norway,
I don't know, it's kind of far,
I don't even know what's in Norway.
There's no benefits to getting
married to someone in Norway,
I'm joking, I'm joking.
Yeah, and then this is
uh, yeah, this is it.
- [Joey] Oh this is
almost what it was like
at the urinal for me.
- [Connor] So when we see
each other at the urinal,
or, you know, how do I say urinal?
- Urinal.
- Is that what Americans say?
- No, that's what the British say, right?
- No, we say urinals.
- Urinal.
- Yeah.
- I thought the British said urinal?
- No, Americans say urinal.
- I've never heard
someone say urinal before.
- I've said urinal.
- I've only heard British
people say urinal.
- You know what? I get confused
on what words I'm saying,
on British and American,
'cause people constantly correct me.
Even though I know I'm not wrong,
but they say, why does
he say it like that?
And then I ended up
unconsciously changing it.
So I go back to the UK
and now everyone mocks me
for sounding American.
- I don't even know what,
like sometimes I say a word
and I don't even know if
that's said in a British way
or an American way anymore.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but that's it.
That's this power point
presentation, boom, done, thank you.
- That was a hell of a presentation,
thank you for your Ted talk, sir.
- Thanks guys.
Why aren't you clapping Meilyne?
Clap louder, Meilyne, I couldn't hear you.
- What lessons did we learn?
- Connor's fans are fucking weird.
- If you are a woman above the age of 35?
- 35, yeah.
- Is that what you think my demo is?
- Yes.
- I don't fucking know.
- I just like older than me.
- Is that what you think
it is? You are correct.
- Listen, you can see-
- How old are you at right now, 24?
- I'm 24, right.
- Okay, so late 20s
- Twenty four and a half year
olds are gonna be like, Ooh.
- I'm in the zone.
(laughing)
- Some people age like wine,
man, they age better, man.
They get more attractive.
Why are you laughing,
Meilyne? It's true though.
It's true.
- Yeah, it's true
- Some people, you see pictures of like,
you see them when they're
younger, like celebrities,
you see them when the
older and you're like,
holy shit, he's 50 but he's
hotter than he ever was.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- I agree.
- Honestly, to me it's like,
as long as the mindset is there
that you're in my world
and you're on the same
wavelength of thinking and
you treat life the same way,
I don't give a fuck about your age.
- Yeah, I feel like some people-
- As long as you're hot.
- I just don't want you
to be younger than me,
I don't wanna fucking
date someone younger.
- I feel like some people
just hit a certain age
and then they just stop giving
a shit about how they look
and taking care of themselves, right?
Or alternatively, they just
think they can get away
with the lifestyle they had in their 20s,
and just bring that to like the-
- 40s and 50s.
- Their entire 30s, 40s and 50s.
'Cause, you know, I think being 30 now,
as the only 30 year old,
I've heard that being 30
is just basically being 20
with one debuff.
- And shit blood.
- Yeah, and shit blood, yeah.
- And yeah, I mean, I feel
like some people do age
like fucking fine wine,
and a lot of Asians just don't age at all,
I guess until they've
reached like this cap,
and then they just start aging like crazy.
- And then they're like,
oh, we have to age, oh okay.
- Yeah, also going back to
the naming me after a baby,
it wasn't an insult by the way,
I just wanna make sure that's clear.
I don't think that's like a bad thing,
it just looked very
intense, just quite a lot.
- I mean, I've never heard
any other story like that.
- It's so overwhelming that you're like,
which emotion do I take away from this?
- I put myself in your
shoes and the biggest, like,
if I'm like trying to be like POV,
you are Connor holding a
baby that's named after you.
I'm like, how do I even-
- Cue the pump music.
(all laughing)
- How do I even manage
what to say right now?
I wouldn't even know how to react.
- It's like a mixture of
overwhelming flattery,
overwhelming, like what the
fuck, are you sure about this?
Are you sure about that?
It's like, is this a mistake?
Are you gonna regret this?
'Cause I'm not all that, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- What else did we take away
from the power point presentation boys?
What did you learn today?
- You get hit on a lot.
- No, no, it's actually... You know what?
- So my audience has gone
from, as we know, 93%,
recently it went to like 60% male.
- It's cause of all the
Jojo shit you've been doing.
- Jojo, I think also there
was a good amount of time
where, I think because of my thumbnails,
because the topics I was covering,
YouTube just didn't recommend me to guys,
and now it's suddenly started being like,
oh wait, guys can watch this guy too.
And so I started getting a
massive influx of guy views
that I never had before,
and I stopped doing as much yowie stuff
and slowed down on that.
But, I mean, it's still like nearly,
it depends on the month,
like depending on the videos I make.
It's about 50, 50 now, which is nice,
and it's slowed down a lot.
But there's ups and downsides, right?
Like it was mainly... I
know that I spoke about,
mainly it was girls coming up to me
but, dude, guys hit on me just as much.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I've had that one as well.
- Which was flattering,
'cause there was like one dude
who was in my Instagram message request,
the man was fucking ripped as fuck,
and I was like, wow, I'm very flattered.
This man had like the
body of a Greek statue
and this man thought I was
worthy of being hit on.
I was very flattered.
- I'm jealous.
- Right? I was like, damn.
But yeah, I mean, it's whatever,
it's just fucking YouTube.
- Yeah. I mean, what I can take about this
is that if there is going to be an avenue,
not necessarily to be hit on,
but for someone to get
in contact with you,
'cause I would say half of
these were just, you know,
the fan interactions
or people trying to get
in contact with you.
If there's an avenue,
people are gonna find a way,
and I've definitely felt
that as YouTuber as well.
- Yeah. I mean, you can hit on me,
it's very flattering, I don't care.
You don't have to stop doing
it, just not be creepy.
- Just do it in a sophisticated way.
- Yeah man, you do it sleek,
I'll be like, thank you for the ego boost.
I'm gonna go away feeling
great, and who doesn't?
Dude, you get hit on
you're like, damn I'm a 10.
And then you go back to your hotel room
and eat a whole bag of
flaming hot Cheetos,
and realize you're truly a five.
- And also, on the opposite
end, taking this advice
for any young budding YouTubers out there,
tread carefully with fans hitting on you.
- Don't fuck your fans,
man. It never works out.
- Listen, you know, it might
work out one tenth of the time,
but the problem is that-
- But are you willing to take the risk?
- Yeah, it's a risk-
- I mean, you have to be really careful,
and I think the biggest problem
is that whenever you're like
a YouTuber starting out,
especially when you're a small YouTuber,
I feel like this is more a
message to small YouTubers
who don't have the experience,
or don't think they're gonna get big,
because you don't fucking know
if you're gonna get big, right?
But you should treat the fans,
or you should treat your audience,
no matter how big you
are, exactly the same.
And stay grounded.
- Yeah. I mean, I'm sure there's
cringy messages out there
of me hitting on someone at 19
that would just embarrass me.
But, again, I'm 19, you
know, just fucking delete it.
- But like, you're like kind of-
- It wasn't like I hit on fans
and be like, send me nudes,
you know what I mean?
It was just like me being an
average 19 year old, basically.
- Exactly, when you're younger
you don't really have the senses
to know what exactly is cringe or not.
- Also when you're younger,
you're just horny as fuck.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And you think you can
get away with being horny,
and you grow up and you realize, man,
I did a lot of stupid shit back then.
- Yeah, young, dumb, and
full of cum, as they say.
- Lovely, Joey. Words to live by.
But I mean, it's like,
'cause there's some people,
you know, there's a lot
of YouTubers out there
who are very openly happy to
admit that they date fans.
They're like, well, you know,
normal famous celebrities
get to fuck their fans
and no one bats an eye,
and it's like, well-
- Yeah, that double standard
propagated, and it's true.
- Yeah, but the reason why,
this is the way I interpret it
and the why that's the case,
that normal celebrities
they don't bank on the fact
of relatability, they don't
bank on the fact of being-
- They're like people above the clouds.
- Like every pop star is
supposed to be like a character,
like an absurd kind of,
not real person, right?
They never pretend to be your friend,
they never like pretend
to give a shit about you,
and if you have sex with them
they probably don't give about it, right?
Maybe, maybe it's just a joke.
But I mean, if you do it
with an influencer, right?
Ugh, a gross word, or a YouTuber, right?
- I hate that word, influencer.
- Influencer.
- I guess it's almost kind of a betrayal
of what you built up which
is like a lot of the people
who watch us, right?
I guess, I don't know if you guys know,
you guys feel this way,
like you form like a bit of a bond, right?
Where you respect the creator
and you look up to them
and you enjoy their stuff,
and you feel a lot closer to a YouTuber,
than you would a normal celebrity.
And so it's that that's
being taken advantage of.
- Right, it's because most
of YouTubers are more,
I guess, grounded, right?
And feel more real,
so when you do watch
them, you're just like,
oh, this is an actual person I'm watching.
- Yeah, I would say the
right way to go about it
if you're going to get
involved with your fans,
one of the biggest things is
you don't do it straight away.
Like you need to treat them-
- Start as a friend.
- Start as a friend, treat
them like a human being,
get to know each other first,
like any normal fucking relationship
- You need to immediately
like break down or disassemble
any power dynamic in play,
of like fan, YouTuber,
you put yourself on equal footing.
- Yeah, and with stuff like
one night stands or something,
that gets so messy,
and there's no way to like differentiate
is there a power dynamic there?
- Is the person gonna do this
and then, you know, regret
it afterwards and just...
It's too messy to be
able to justify, I feel,
and there is a right
way to go about it and-
- There's lots of ways to go about it,
but most of the time it's like, you know,
do you wanna diffuse a bomb?
If you know how to, and you
wanna do that, go ahead.
- There's a right way to do it
but it's not worth the
risk most of the time.
- Yeah, but is it worth-
- Is it worth the risk?
- It's not worth the risk.
- You're literally blowing
yourself up in terms of career.
Like, is it worth it? Or you
could just, I don't know,
do what everyone else
fucking does in the world,
and just date normally.
- And I feel like a lot
of smaller YouTubers,
they don't really think about this
because they think I've
got nothing to lose,
so I'm just gonna do this
right now while I can.
Because you grow up in
a culture where, yeah,
you do see, you know,
celebrities and like groupies
sleeping with, you know, music artists
and everything like
that, and you think, man,
that sounds like an awesome lifestyle,
I kind of want that lifestyle.
So when they get like a smidgen of that
they think I gotta take advantage of this
while I still can.
- The rock and roll lifestyle
works if you're in that field,
the rock and roll lifestyle
is not the YouTuber lifestyle,
it's two completely
different things, I find.
- Yeah. it's tough, it's so tough,
and it's not even worth
like getting into, right?
- Yeah, 'cause I feel like
to get involved in this,
you are literally navigating a minefield.
- Oh yeah, 100%.
It's like if you really
wanna do it, you can do it,
but the reason why I think
most YouTubers will say
don't fuck your fans is
because it's just like
it's so much risk you're
taking on for no reason.
And to me it's like, do
you really want someone
who wants to be with you for your videos?
Why is that attractive?
- They're looking at you only
for the content you make.
- To me it's a competitive mindset.
- To me, that's like a massive turnoff.
If they're only with me
because of my content,
then that's like...
The same thing, if you're
only my friends for my content
then you can't be my friend,
because that's not how
I would see a friend,
the same way that's how I
wouldn't see a possible partner
or anything like that.
- That's like saying like,
oh, so if I change my content
then you're suddenly not my friend.
- Yeah.
- There is no bigger turn on, right?
Than meeting someone who
just likes you for you.
- Yeah.
- I'm sitting there thinking like,
how the fuck am I
supposed to be into this,
and then like get my dick hard
when all I'm thinking about,
you're thinking is like, what's
the next upload gonna be?
You know what I mean? Like, fuck that.
No, I want someone who speaks to me,
knows nothing about YouTube,
and is like, holy shit,
this guy's fucking cool,
I like him, he's so nice.
- You want people to see
you as Connor not CdDawgVA.
- Yeah, which obviously I made
a bit difficult for myself,
obviously, but I can still go about it.
- Yeah, of course
- You don't wanna be with a
girl, be in bed and be like,
yo, if you enjoyed that
session, hit the subscribe,
and click the like button.
(all laughing)
- If we get to 5,000
likes, I'll do round two.
(all laughing)
- I want video a YouTube video
of someone trying to do that.
- I feel like... Oh my God, yeah,
there's just so many
douche-tubers out there
who do shit like that.
- There are.
- I'm sure there's YouTubers out there
who will just admit
every single fucking day,
like, yeah, I fucked my fans so what?
I mean, screw them. But if
you wanna have like, you know-
- If you wanna be
respected by the community
- Yeah, if you wanna be
seen as like a role model,
I don't know what that is.
- I mean, like douche-tubers,
I feel, just exist on a
different plane of existence
where, I don't know how
they function or, you know-
- I just want YouTubers to
have a better rep, right?
Like not all of us are
fucking psychopath, uh,
validating chasing,
- Money hungry.
- Yeah, a lot of us are horny
motherfuckers and that's just-
- That's just human nature.
- A lot of us are horny
but we do it the right way.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- "Mother Knows Breasts"
on Blu-ray, you know?
- We are three horny guys, but
at least we're horny on main,
and we keep to being horny on main
and that's pretty much it.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- A part of me is glad,
is that I have YouTube to
keep me in check almost,
not that I would start doing awful shit
if I wasn't a YouTuber.
But the fact that there
is this kind of like
obvious moral lines that it's not like,
oh no, man, should I do.., No, it's not.
- They're like these
unspoken guidelines and rules
to like, make sure
you're not overstepping.
- Being an ass, right?
- Yeah.
- It really makes me cautious
about how I come off to people
and what I say to people, it
makes me way more conscious
about how I speak in a
way that I think is...
You know, the way I speak on live streams,
the way I speak, you know, on the video
is how I'll speak to
most people in my life.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I like that it's kind
of taught me, in a way,
to just be, it sounds awful, right?
But just give a shit about
everything and pay attention
even if it is draining at times.
It sounds awful, I'm like,
you should have taught me
to be not an asshole.
But like, you know how some
things you take for granted
when you're an individual
who isn't like a open person.
- Yeah. I mean, for me,
it didn't teach me to give
a shit about everything,
but it did teach me to really
question my own values.
- [Connor] That's a
better way of putting it.
- Yeah, and really justify,
is this value I hold right?
As opposed to like, I'll just think about,
I just think of it this way,
because I grew up in
that kind of environment,
and it really made me self reflect.
And I feel like that is like
a healthy part of YouTube,
I think I've become a better
person because of YouTube.
- Yeah, it's about that mentality of like,
okay, if I wasn't doing
YouTube, then are the things
that I do and the way
that I talk to people
and that kind stuff,
would that be still considered
respectful to other people,
regardless of if I had this job or not.
Would I still be a good person
if I didn't have YouTube?
And if the answer is yes,
then I think if you're following it right.
- Very worrying if the answer is no.
- Yeah.
Well, I mean, you know, look
at all the douche-tubers,
apparently you can get away with that shit
if you have a YouTube channel.
- I don't know, do they get
away with that shit though?
- I mean, there's a reason
why they have an audience.
- They're on borrowed time.
- Are they looking at tweet
longer, waiting to happen?
- They're not gonna be at
the point that they are
for very long
- Because I feel like a big,
I mean, this is getting to
a really deep topic now,
but a big problem with a lot
of these like apology videos,
and, you know, a lot
of this kind of culture
that has been built up, I
understand where it comes from,
where we do need to
keep each other in check
and make sure that people
aren't abusing their power.
But a part of it just
makes me feel like, man,
people are just treating this
like one big reality TV show.
- Yeah, it's not keeping each other check,
we've just made it a modern Coliseum.
- We just gamified it basically.
- Yeah, you know, we
can't kill each other,
this is the best thing we can do,
is fucking get at each
other's throats online.
- Yeah, which is why now
when I see an apology video
or a tweet longer, you know,
a lot of like, as we said,
we were taught to have to
give a shit about this thing
but sometimes I see this and I'm like,
I don't have the energy
to care about this,
this doesn't involve me.
You know, sometimes it fucking sucks
when I hear about, you know,
some person in the community
or in some community that
I'm not even involved in,
having like a 50 page dissertation
breaking down every
shitty thing they've done.
And I'm like, I'm sorry
that this happened,
but at the same time, like
I don't have the energy
to invest myself into this.
Can someone literally give me a cliff note
of what's going on?
And like, I don't want to be the guy
to be like can you tell me what to think?
But there reaches a point
where there's too much happening
right now that you can-
- It's like sensory overload of drama.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it's just like,
at the end of the day
all I'm seeing is someone's
getting fucking paid leave,
that's all I'm seeing.
- Yeah.
- It's like I have limited
time, I have limited energy,
and I wanna be able to use it
on shit I actually care about.
- Yeah, I would like to care
about every big scandal,
every big thing that gets
brought up on Twitter,
and, you know, that's, logically,
and if I would think about it
that's what I want to value,
but logistically you can't.
You can't care about this much shit,
and I feel like a big problem right now
is that this entire environment
just feels like "Big Brother",
or this feels like a reality TV show
where people care, but
do they really care?
Like it gets to a point
where, does this really...
Where I think, does this
is really involve me,
you know, am I doing
something right to society
by getting involved with this,
or am I just feeding
the fumes and the fire
and just making the
environment more toxic?
- If you have thick enough
skin, nothing's stopping you.
If you don't care that everyone hates you,
and you're fine with that,
then there's literally
nothing stopping you
from succeeding on YouTube.
- I mean, there's people who make a career
off of being hated.
- Yeah, plenty.
- Yeah, I mean, one of
the biggest examples,
is of course, Logan Paul.
I can't remember who said this quote
but I think it was like
Muhammad Ali or a boxer,
where they said something like,
if people will pay to like... What was it?
People will pay to shut you up.
- Yeah, people will pay
to watch you get punched
- Yeah, watch you get punched,
or watch you shut the fuck up,
something along those lines.
And man, Logan Paul has
capitalized that to the max.
I mean, I'll fucking admit, you know,
I got involved with whenever Logan Paul
gets into a boxing match
- I watched the boxing
matches, of course I did,
I wanna see Logan Paul
get punched a bunch.
It's just funny, you know?
I mean, I don't really
have anything personally
against the guy, obviously,
but it's just fun seeing two YouTubers
smack each other in the face.
This shit's funny as fuck.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- I'd do that if the right target came up.
I'm like, yo, how much money did he make?
Put me in the ring, give
me some beef, please.
- Give me some beef to fight over.
- Pay per view, anyone?
- It's scary.
Scary how it's evolved
to that point, isn't it?
It makes you wonder what the next step is.
- We're going back to where we started,
where, you know, when
reality is this entertaining,
who the fuck needs TV?
- That's what I've been saying
the whole time gone, Garnt.
Reality has always been more entertaining.
- Documentaries are the new movies.
- Yeah, man, you can't
make this shit up, man.
You can make up all these "Harry Potters"
and "Lord Of The Rings",
that's epic and all,
I love those films but you
can't make up the weird shit
that happens in real life.
And that's been "Trash Taste".
But you know what hasn't
been "Trash Taste"?
Without us reading the Patreons,
that didn't make any sense.
- That made no sense at all.
I was like, where are you going with this?
- Let's do it, "Trash Taste" Patreon, woo!
- Yeah, look at all these Patreons.
- They love him.
- This guy has giga-brain,
giga monkey brain.
- Yeah.
- Hey, if you'd like to join the Patreon,
then as always, go to
patreon.com/trashtaste,
also follow us on Twitter, the subreddit.
- You'll get clips early from the episode